MARC LEVINE AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTERNATIONAL AND REGIONAL
AGREEMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WHERE WE
WILL DISCUSS THE WESTERN STATES
PACKED BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
OREGON WASHINGTON. NEVADA AND
COLORADO. I WANT TO THINK THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PER. TODAY SOME
MEMBER TASHA BOERNER HORVATH
ESPECIALLY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON TIME AND- FOR EVERYONE
WHO IS PARTICIPATING IN IN IN
FACT THE PANELISTS WHO OUT WILL
BE PARTICIPATING. BY PHONE AS
WELL AS IN PERSON FOR COMING
AND PROVIDING THEIR EXPERTISE.
IT'S CHALLENGING TO DO IT
DURING- THE PANDEMIC SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND INCLUDING- THE
SERGEANTS AND STAFF WHO ARE
MAKING TODAY POSSIBLE FOR ALL
OF US. DUE TO THE CURRENT STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE. IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ONLY
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND
WATCH HERE IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM- BUT WE'VE GOT A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY. I WHICH
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SO HERE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT INTO
THE ROOM TODAY IT IS IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. WE'RE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER UP THE
PUBLIC MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN. SIX FEET OF SPACE IN
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THE LARGER
OF THAT THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
THAT WERE AND SO THAT MAKES IT.
A LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS. FOR THE
PUBLIC. AT GOOD MORNING WELCOME
THING YOU SO MUCH JOINING THE
SUMMER THEM WATER. THANK YOU
AND TO WHAT FOR THE- OF TO AN
AND THE KEY. AND FOR THOSE OF
THAT TO OUR AT THE HERE TODAY
IF ANY MAN OF THE- IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE GOT THE
DISTANCE SEEN. THAT WE NEED I
WOULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONES. AND
TRUST THAT THE MICROPHONE WILL
PICK UP. YOUR VOICE- OR THAT
YOU ADJUST YOUR BODY- A LITTLE
BIT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN-
BE PICKED UP BY THE MICROPHONE.
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MICROPHONE CAN BE
USED. BY MORE THAN ONE PERSON.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM.
ONCE YOU ARE FINISHED.
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT OR YOU
CAN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE
BE SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME AND THE
SERGEANTS WILL ASSIST YOU. TO
OUT TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
PROPERLY. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CALLING IN. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
MEMBER OFTHE PUBLIC CAN
PROVIDE COMMENTARY WHEN WE GET
TO THAT POINT. IN THE AGENDA.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN THREE FOUR FIVE ONE
THREE ONE. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN THREE FOUR FIVE ONE THREE
ONE. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE SCREEN OF THE
LIVE STREAM IF YOU ARE WATCHING
THE LIVE STREAM WHICH YOU CAN
FIND FROM THE ASSEMBLY IS
WEBSITE. AND FROM THE SELECT
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND THAT
THAT CAN BE FOUND AT TO
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV AND THE
SELECT COMMITTEES THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTERNATIONAL AND
REGIONAL AGREEMENTS IF YOU'RE
HAVING A HARD TIME FINDING IT.
IF YOU ARE CALLING IN THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE BE
SURE TO ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE AND THAT SO
pTHIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUNDS DISTORTION. ONCE YOUARE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE YOU WILL
ALSO NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF INTO
UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL MY
OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO ONE ZERO AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. THANK YOU BYE LIKE
STAFF FOR HELPING PEOPLE WITH
THAT. THANK YOU ALL FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT WE
ALL FACE. I LEFT WITH THAT
LET'S HIT RESET AND- AND START
I AM MARC LEVINE AND WELCOME
TODAY'S HEARING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTERNATIONAL AND
REGIONAL AGREEMENTS. TODAY WE
ARE LOOKING INTO THE WESTERN
STATES PACKED. WE'RE STARING
DOWN THE FACE OF THE GREATEST
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. IN A
CENTURY LED BY SCIENCE AND DATA
BAY AREA PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
INSTITUTED THE FIRST DAY AT
HOME ORDERS IN THE NATION. ON
MARCH SIXTEENTH. THEIR FEARLESS
LEADERSHIP IS SAVING LIVES TO
THEM I SAY THANK YOU. DAYS
LATER GOVERNOR NEWSOME
ESTABLISHED A STATEWIDE STAY AT
HOME ORDER ACROSS ALL FIFTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES WHICH
EXTENDED THIS LIFESAVING
MEASURE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
PRIOR WE SAW THE STEP TAKEN IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND WE'VE ALSO
SENSING THIS REPLICATED ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES. EVEN
LIFESAVING INSTINCTS HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WITH
THE BILL TAKING A FAX COVE IN
NINETEEN IS TAKING A TOLL. ON
HUMAN HEALTH. AND LIVES AND
ALSO ON LOCAL AND GLOBAL
ECONOMIES. WE ARE NOW FACE THE
DILEMMA OF HOW TO RELAX
LIFESAVING MEASURES WHILE
BREEDING LIFE BACK INTO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS IN THE NORTHEAST AND
ALONG THE WEST COAST ON APRIL
THIRTEENTH ANNOUNCED SEPARATE
STATE COMPACTS TO COORDINATE
ONE OF THEIR BIGGEST CHALLENGES
IN THE WEEKS TO COME. HOW TO
BEGIN RE OPENING SOCIETY A MIG
AMID THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC.
THE GOVERNOR IS MADE SEPARATE
ANNOUNCEMENTS JUST HOURS AFTER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP SAID ON
TWITTER. THAT IT WAS HIS
DECISION TO DECIDE WHEN TO OPEN
UP THE STATE'S WE KNOW THAT
ISN'T THE CASE AND WE KNOW THAT
TO DO IT PROPERLY IT WILL TAKE
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THE
MULTI STATE COUNCIL INCLUDES
CONNECTICUT DELAWARE NEW JERSEY
NEW YORK PENNSYLVANIA AND RHODE
ISLAND. IN A NEWS RELEASE ON
APRIL SIXTEENTH A BIPARTISAN
GROUP OF GOVERNORS OF ILLINOIS
INDIANA KENTUCKY MICHIGAN
MINNESOTA IOWA AND WISCONSIN.
ANNOUNCED A MULTI STATE
AGREEMENT KNOWN AS THE
MIDWESTERN STATES PARTNERSHIP
TO DISCUSS RE OPENING THE
ECONOMIES OF THEIR STATES
TOGETHER. THE RELEASE SAID THAT
WHILE THERE THE STATE'S WOULD
WORK TOGETHER ON THE PLAN. THEY
MAY NOT EACH TAKE THE SAME
STEPS TO RE OPEN AT THE SAME
TIME. MAINE VERMONT NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND HAVE TALKED ABOUT
A PARTNERSHIP IN THE SOUTHERN
STATES COALITION OF ALABAMA.
FLORIDA SOUTH CAROLINA GEORGIA
AND TENNESSEE. ALSO FORMED. WE
ARE IN THE WESTERN STATES
PACKED WHICH INCLUDES THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OREGON WASHINGTON
COLORADO AND NEVADA. THE PACT
RESOLVE TO RE OPEN THEIR
RESPECTIVE ECONOMIES BASED ON
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND SCIENCE NOT
POLITICS. AND ON APRIL
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME UNVEILED THE
SIX CRITICAL INDICATORS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THAT WOULD BE
THE FRAMEWORK FOR GUIDING
DECISIONS ON RE OPENING. THESE
INDICATORS ARE ONE THE ABILITY
TO MONITOR AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH TESTING
CONTACT TRACING ISOLATING AND
SUPPORTING THOSE FOR POSITIVE
OR EXPOSED. TO THE ABILITY TO
PREVENT INFECTION IN PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT RISK FOR MORE SEVERE
COVE IN NINETEEN. THREE THE
ABILITY OF THE HOSPITAL AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS TO HANDLE
SEARCHES FOR. THE ABILITY TO
DEVELOP THERAPEUTICS TO MEET
THE DEMAND. FIVE THE ABILITY
FOR BUSINESSES SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AND SIXTY
ABILITY TO DETERMINE WHEN TO
REINSTITUTE CERTAIN MEASURES
SUCH AS THE STAY AT HOME ORDERS
IF NECESSARY. ON MAY ELEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY THE WESTERN SIX
PACK JOINTLY WROTE A LETTER TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REQUESTING ONE TRILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESPONDING TO THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SINCE
THEN. PRESSURE HAS MOUNTED ON
GOVERNOR'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO RE OPEN THEIR ECONOMIES WITH
PROTESTS OUTSIDE CAPITOL
BUILDINGS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITHIN STATES
CALLING FOR REGIONALLY BASED RE
OPENING. WITH A SURGE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT NEARING GREAT
DEPRESSION LEVELS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE PUBLIC IS
INFORMED AND ENGAGED ON EVERY
ASPECT OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
AFFECT THEIR LIVELIHOODS. AND
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR
FAMILIES. IT WAS MY HOPE THAT
REPRESENTATIVES OF THIS STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE WESTERN STATES
WOULD BE PRESENT. BUT THEY WILL
NOT BE PARTICIPATING. DESPITE
THIS COMMITTEES INVITATION.
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IS NOT
LIMITED IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN FACT THIS ADMINISTRATION'S
DEMONSTRATED THAT A FULLY
ENGAGED GOVERNMENT IS NEEDED AS
MUCH AS EVER THE ADAGE THAT IF
YOU WANT TO GO FAST GO ALONE.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO FAR GO
TOGETHER RINGS TRUE THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO WELL TO
REMEMBER THAT. AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME REMARKS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. MS
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOOKING FOR
MEANING THAT HEARING I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT
HOW THE WESTERN STATES ARE
COORDINATING ESPECIALLY AS WE
LOOK FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY HOW
ARE WE GOING TO COORDINATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SO IT'S NOT
JUST DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
RECOVERY AFTERWARDS WE KNOW
THAT OUR ECONOMIES OF THE
WESTERN STATES ARE.
INTRINSICALLY INTERTWINED AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING-
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN THE
SAME WAY TO PREVENT A SECOND
SEARCH OF THIS VIRUS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
FOR GIVING HERE TODAY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE TESTIMONY
IS THAT WE'RE GONNA HERE TAKING
HIS BROTHER ARE A MISS COME
UNDER. THANK YOU. CHAIR THANK
YOU CHAIR FOR THIS SELECT.
INCREDIBLY TIMELY ESPECIALLY AS
WE ALL BEGIN TO LOOK AT RE
OPENING THE STATE AND WHAT IT
MEANS. I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ENCINITAS
THAT- COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AND
AGREEMENTS- ON THIS SIDE OF THE
COASTER ON THIS COAST IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. WE
BENEFIT FROM- GREAT TOURISM
DOLLARS- AND INTEREST FROM SO
MANY FOLKS AROUND THE WORLD-
WHO WANT TO COME TO ALL OF OUR
STATES BUT PARTICULARLY TO
CALIFORNIA AND SO HOW WE FOR
THE RED. THIS NEEDLE AROUND
KEEPING OUR CONSTITUENTS SAFE
AND RESUSCITATING OUR ECONOMIES
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE INFORMATION
THAT WILL BE SURE TODAY ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER MR AS
ERIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND IT IS VERY TIMELY ECHOING
THE COMMENTS OF MY TWO PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE- IDEA.
WHAT I PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE
ABOUT THIS HEARING IS THAT
GIVEN THE TOTAL COMPLETE
FAILURE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE. AND
FORCING FIFTY STATES TO COME UP
WITH FIFTY DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS.
IT'S BEEN I THINK A VERY
WELCOMED ASSESSMENT AND
APPROACH BY THE WESTERN STATES
TO GET TOGETHER AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THEY CAN LEARN
FROM ONE ANOTHER AND BENEFIT
FROM- ECONOMIES OF SCALE
MISTAKES BEST PRACTICES AND
EVERYTHING THAT. THAT BRING
STRENGTH IN NUMBERS AND- IN
DOING THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET A
FEW THINGS WRONG. AND SO
HEARINGS LIKE THIS ALLOW FOR US
TO HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT'S WORKED WHAT HASN'T
WORKED AND- WATER ASSESSMENTS
AND EVALUATIONS ARE SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
NAZARIAN SO. AS STATED EARLIER
WELL UNFORTUNATELY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY THE
GOVERNOR'S LEGISLATIVE
SECRETARY ANTHONY WILLIAMS. DID
SUBMIT A LETTER DESCRIBING THE
NATURE OF THE ONGOING
COLLABORATION BETWEEN. THE FIVE
STATES I ALSO HAD A VERY
PLEASANT MEETING WITH THAT MR
WILLIAMS AND MISS AND ALL OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ABOUT THE
ON GOING WORK OF THE WESTERN
STATES PACKED. AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND ALSO THE
ATTENTION THAT THEY ARE PUTTING
TO- PROTECTING LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS. THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME IS SINGULARLY FOCUSED
ON PROTECTING AND SAVING THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
CALIFORNIA IS A MASSIVE STATE.
WE ARE FORTY MILLION STRONG
WITH FIFTY EIGHT VERY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. SOME SAY IT IS ON
GOVERNOR BOWL. EVEN IN GOOD
TIMES AND THE PANDEMIC
COMPLICATES THAT REALITY. AS
DESCRIBED EARLIER GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN PARTISAN
LINES HAVE SOUGHT ALLIANCES. TO
PLAN OUR WAY THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC IN A GRADUAL OPENING
OF OUR ECONOMIES SOME OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THE MULTI
STATE COUNCIL. HAVE ENGAGE IN
PROCUREMENT PRACTICES TOGETHER.
PROCUREMENT SPECIFICALLY OF PP
IS- PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT IS A SUBJECT THAT
GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
ACROSS THE GLOBE. IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PRESENT TODAY
WE'D BE ABLE TO ASK ABOUT-
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
ON HOW THEY ARE PRE CURRYING.
AT PP- AND DOING IT
INDEPENDENTLY OF COURSE AS A
STATE OF FORTY MILLION WHILE-
THE MULTI STATE COUNCIL IS
WORKING TOGETHER TO COORDINATE-
PROCUREMENT AND EVEN
MANUFACTURING AND I THINK THAT
COMPARATIVE ANALYSIS IS ONE.
THAT WILL BE MISSED- DIRECTLY
ENGAGING THE ADMINISTRATION BUT
WE HAVE STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
ABLE TO TALK TO US ABOUT THOSE
CHALLENGES. AND ALSO- WHY
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE IN THE WAY
THAT WE- EXPERIENCE THE
PANDEMIC AND HOW WE HAVE TO
APPROACH THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE BEFORE US. WE ALSO ARE
MISSING OPPORTUNITIES TO SHARE-
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE ABOUT
HOW OUR PARTNERS ARE DEALING
WITH. THE SPREAD OF COVERED
NINETEEN. IN NURSING FACILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE'S ENGAGED IN
THE PACKED AND WHAT CALIFORNIA
HAS LEARNED OF THAT TO PROTECT.
OUR SENIORS AND THE ELDERLY IN
NURSING FACILITIES. FROM CODE
NINETEEN. WE ALSO- AS WE ARE
PUSH MEMORIAL DAY. I HAVE A
LOOSENING OF RESTRICTIONS THAT
COMES JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AFTER THE- LOOSENING OF MAY
FOURTH AND WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE. IN INFECTIONS SINCE
THAT TIME. PARTICULARLY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- THAT
SHOULD HELP INFORM THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE MAKING
TODAY- GOING FORWARD. SO AT
THIS TIME- I WILL BE INVITING
THE PANELISTS TO COME UP AND-
AND GIVE PRESENTATIONS AND SO-
GOOD- WE DO HAVE OUR FIRST
PANELIST WHO IS HERE IN PERSON-
MISTER JAIME JOHANNSEN
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION. AND WHAT I
WILL- ADVISE YOU AS AS I WILL
ADVISE THOSE FOR JOINING BY
TELEPHONE. WHEN I ASKED THE
MODERATOR TO- TO BRING THEM ON
TO INTO THE MEETING- WILL BE TO
YOU KNOW PLEASE. INTRODUCE
YOURSELF OF COURSE TALK TO US
ABOUT HOW YOUR ORGANIZATION IS
DEALING WITH THIS FOR YOUR
MEMBERS AND THIS PART OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU MISTER
HANSON. WELL THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TALK- I'M JAMIE
JOHANNSON PRESENT A CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WE REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS GENERAL
AG ORGANIZATION SO WE REPRESENT
EVERYONE FROM DAIRY FARMERS TO-
WINE GRAPE GROWERS TALL A
FARMER SUCH AS MYSELF AND
CITRUS GROWERS UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA. FIFTY THREE COUNTY
FARM BUREAU'S FROM PERIL UP TO
MODOC SO- AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
ON. THE MARCH SIXTEENTH MAR
SEVENTEENTH. HOW BUSY WE BEEN
GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
MEMBERS OF WHAT. THEY HAD TO DO
WE START BY SAYING ONE OF THE
GREAT. WHAT A REALLY IMPORTANT
ACTION AND IT WAS- IT HELPED
OUR MEMBERS WHO WAS THE
INTERPRETATION ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AGRICULTURE
BEING A PART OF THAT.
CALIFORNIA WAS VERY LIBERAL IN
HOW THEY DID IT- MEANING ALL OF
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING OUR
NURSERIES AND HORTICULTURAL'S
SOME STATES THAT WAS NOT THE
CASE BUT IN CALIFORNIA. ALL OF
AGRICULTURE WAS ABLE TO REMAIN
OPEN- AND THAT HELPED GREATLY
THE NEXT QUESTION WAS HOW DO WE
KEEP OUR EMPLOYEE SAFE IN OUR
FAMILIES- SO- WE BEGIN THOSE
IMPLEMENTATIONS MONTEREY COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE TOOK THE
INITIATIVE. EXCUSE ME. I TOOK
THE INITIATIVE AND- CAME UP
WITH THEIR OWN PARAMETERS OF
HOW TO KEEP EMPLOYEES SAFE
VOLUNTARILY WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY AS WELL AS MONTEREY
COUNTY FARM BUREAU AND OTHER
AGRICULTURAL GROUPS- SOON
ADOPTED VOLUNTARILY AROUND THE
STATE I KNOW WE KEPT UP TO DATE
ON OUR SITE- ALMOST WEEKLY
UPDATES OF WHAT WE CAN DO. TO
INCREASE THE EFFECTIVENESS
BEYOND WHAT THE REGULATIONS
WERE- A TERMS OF SEPARATION
BOTH IN OUR PROCESSING PLANTS
IN THE FIELD AND ALSO HONOR
TRACTORS AND- PLANTERS. WITH I
THINK GREAT SUCCESS WE DID NOT
SEE THE OUTBREAK OF COVERT
NINETEEN AMONGST OUR WORKERS
LIKE THIS THE VERY- UPSETTING
STORIES THAT WE SEE IN SOME OF
OUR- MIDWEST STATES- THERE BUT
THAT REALLY IS THE INITIATIVE
TAKEN BY CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. WE SOON CAME OUT WITH
A POLL AFTERWARDS- SO THIS THIS
POLL IS ABOUT THREE WEEKS OLD
FOUR WEEKS OLD WE PLANET
UPDATING IN TERMS OF GETTING. A
FEELING OF HOW OUR MEMBERS ARE
BEING AFFECTED AND HOW THEY'RE
DEALING WITH IT- AND MAKE NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT THERE IS VERY
LITTLE THAT. WILL BE VERY FEW
IN AGRICULTURE WHO WILL
UNTOUCHED BY THIS PANDEMIC.
WE'VE HAD A GENERATIONAL EVENT
THE GENERATIONAL EVENT THAT
WILL BRING ABOUT SOME CHANGES
AND IT WILL ALSO BRING ABOUT
CHANGES IN HOW WE DO OUR
BUSINESS WE UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
HOW DO WE DO THAT EFFECTIVELY.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE COMING OUT OF THIS IS
FURTHER CONSOLIDATION IN TERMS
OF- EITHER NEW REGULATIONS OR
JUST HOW WE DO BUSINESS AND
THEN OF COURSE. THE MOST UP
SETTING AS OUR CUSTOMERS
OVERNIGHT WE WOKE UP AT 50% OF
OUR CUSTOMERS. WERE BUSINESSES
WERE PUT ON HOLD. 50% OF WHAT
WE GROW IN AGRICULTURE
GENERALLY GOES TO- CAN SUIT
THAT GOES TO RESTAURANTS AND
FOOD SERVICES. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY AND WE'RE
SEEING GEHRY PRICES NOW WE
MEASURE AND HUNDRED WAIT. TEN
DOLLAR AT YOU KNOW ELEVEN
DOLLAR TEN DOLLAR HUNDRED WAIT
UP PRICES THAT'S UNHEARD OF.
COMING FROM SIXTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN JUST DAYS BEFORE. BUT
FOR THE DURING SHE FOR EXAMPLE
THE SHUT DOWN OF THE SCHOOLS
WAS DRAMATIC THE LARGEST
CONSUMER FLUID MILK. IN THE
UNITED STATES IS OUR IS OUR
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM IN OUR
BREAKFAST PROGRAM. CELLS
IMMEDIATE HIDDEN OF COURSE IN
THEIR INDUSTRY 60% OF CHEESE
GENERALLY ENDS UP INTO A FOOD
SERVICE. SO JUST JUST ONE OF
THE EXAMPLES AND OF COURSE YOU
<c.yellow>NOW THE BEEF INDUSTRY
AND WE</c>
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
POULTRY AS WELL. WHAT IS WE
ASK. OUR CUT AS OUR MEMBERS WAS
HAVE YOU LOST CUSTOMERS OUR
SALES AND LIKE I SAID EVERYONE
WILL BE TOUCHED BY THIS
REMEMBER THIS IS THREE WEEKS
AGO. WE ARE COMING INTO THE
HIGH SEASON APARTMENTS IN THE
HIGH SEASON OF SALES. AS WE
MOVE INTO THE SUMMER SPRING AND
SUMMER MONTHS WITH STONE FRUIT
COMING ON AND CULMINATING IN
THE FALL WHEN WE'RE PEAK
HARVEST WITH FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND- SEASONAL WORKERS
EMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW OUR AROUND THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. WE ASKED OUR MEMBERS
HAVE YOU LOST CUSTOMERS ARE
STILL 57% SAID YES- OF THOSE
51% SAID THEY LOST THOSE
CUSTOMERS BECAUSE OF A CLOSED
THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS FOR
THOSE BUSINESSES. AND THEN OF
COURSE ONE THING TO REMEMBER IS
THE IMPACT WE HAD IN OUR
FARMERS MARKETS THERE ARE SOME.
THERE ARE SOME CONFUSION
TRANSIT THEY WORK IF THEY COULD
STAY OPEN AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WE WORKED AROUND
THAT WITH THE STATE. THANK YOU
TO SECRETARY RAWSON CFA. NOW
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO OPEN IN
PARAMETERS AND CHANGING THEIR
ADAPTING ON THE FLIGHT HOW THEY
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS BUT AT
FIRST. THE IMPACT WAS 21% OF
OUR MEMBERS HAD LOST SALES.
DIRECT CONSUMER SALES JUST
BECAUSE THE UNEASINESS THE
CONSUMER FELT. TO COME OUT AND
TO PURCHASE THAT. AS OF AS
SOMEONE WHO PARTICIPATED FOR
MANY YEARS IN A FARMER'S MARKET
THAT'S A DEVASTATING BLOW. AND
FOR ALL OF US THAT ARE SMALL TO
MEDIUM SIZED FARMS CASH FLOW IS
IMPORTANT AND EVERY WEEK
MATTERS. SO WE KNOW THAT THAT
THEY WERE STRUGGLING OUT THERE
THE OTHER WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
MOST PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE. IS
THAT AROUND A THIRD 240% OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE FARMERS. FARMS
DEPEND ON OFF FARM INCOME. A
SPOUSE OR PARTNER. THAT HAS A
JOB OFF THE FORM NOT IS
GENERALLY ASSOCIATED WITH WITH
AGRICULTURE. SO YES THAT
QUESTION. AS YOUR IMMEDIATE
FAMILY LOST OFF FARM INCOME THE
QUESTION WAS 42% SAID YES.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
WAS THAT ABOUT 60% OF COURSE
WAS THE UNAVAILABLE.
UNAVAILABLE JOB DUE TO SHUT
DOWN ORDERS. BUT AS WITH
EVERYONE ELSE THIRTY SEVEN
PERCENT. HAD COULDN'T GO TO
WORK BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF DAY
CARE AND THE CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS
IN THE IMPACT ON OUR CHILDREN
HAVE TO STAY HOME. WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND CERTAINLY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WORKED ON
AGRICULTURE TO ASSURE EVEN OUR
WORKERS. AS WE ASK THEM THE
FIRST RULE IF YOU FEEL SICK
DON'T COME TO WORK- AND WORK IN
THOSE PARAMETERS AND ALSO.
WORKING WITH RECENT LEGISLATION
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. OF
THE NEEDY. STILL. I PAID TO
STAY HOME TO TAKE CARE OF A
CHILD. WHO WAS IN A TO GO TO.
OR TO. SO THERE THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE PUT IN THE- UNLESS
FEW MONTHS AS WELL. AT REALLY
THE BIGGEST ONE HAVE YOU HAD TO
CEASE ANY OPERATION 76% SAID
NO. AND THEN HAVE YOU BEEN
PREVENTED FROM UNDERTAKING AND
THIS IS THIS IS THE-
INTERESTING ONES WOULD EXPECT.
HAVE YOU BEEN PREVENTED FROM
UNDERTAKING AB NOR ANY AT ANY
NORMAL PLANTING CULTIVATION
CROP CARE DUE TO LACK OF PP
EASE. OF COURSE THE THIRD SAID
YES THEY WERE UNABLE TO THEY
HAD TO PUT OFF WORK BECAUSE OF.
CERTAIN JOBS THAT WE DO REQUIRE
CERTAIN. PP TO BE PROVIDED OF
COURSE 66% OF THAT WAS BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF THE AN NINETY FIVE
MASS- THAT WE ON THE WITH THE
SHORTAGE OF. AS WELL AS AND
SIXTY SIX ARE SORRY 27% BECAUSE
OF THE PROPER GLOVES WEREN'T
AVAILABLE. PP IS A BIG DEAL FOR
AGRICULTURE GOING FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IN TERMS OF
AVAILABILITY. THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION IN TERMS OF THE AN
NINETY FIVE MASK AND ALSO THE
KC NINETY FIVE THE END NINETY
FIVE IS THE APPROPRIATE. THE
MASS THAT IS APPROVED TO-
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF KOBE OR
ALSO IN TERMS OF PARTICULAR
MATTERS THAT WE DEAL WITH ON
THE FARM AS REGULATED BY CAL
OSHA- BUT- THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION IF THE K. NINETY FIVE
COULD QUALIFY ACTORS EVEN
CONFUSION OF KATE. THE CAN
NINETY FIVE. IS AN APPROPRIATE
MASS TO WEAR IN PLACE OF AN AND
NINETY FIVE. JUST ON FEDERAL
AND STATE REGULATIONS KIND OF
SOME CONFLICTING INFORMATION
THEY ARE GETTING A- A COHESIVE.
RULING SOMETHING WE'RE FINDING
AS WELL ON AGRICULTURE. IS THAT
AS WE DEAL WITH THE REGULATIONS
THAT WERE REQUIRED TO DO. AT
TIMES THEY ARE UNEQUALLY
APPLIED ACROSS THE STATE
SOMETIMES. A REGULATOR HAS A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION THE
SOUTH AND THEY DO IN THE NORTH.
SO THERE IS SOME CONFUSION AND
OF COURSE PANIC- IN TERMS OF
WHAT. HOW DO WE STAY COMPLIANT
THE LAST THING WE NEED AT THIS
TIME IS A FINE- BUT- SO THAT
SOMETHING GOING FORWARD THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO- HOW DO WE- HOW
DO WE- MAKE THAT MORE
CONSISTENT- AND OF COURSE. ONE
THING WE'RE PROUD OF IT AND-
WAS THAT 75% OF OUR RESPONDENTS
SAID THEY AVOIDED- FOR LOWING
ARE LAYING OFF EMPLOYEES. AN
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER CONSIDERED
THE CIRCUMSTANCES- OVERALL. ONE
OF THINGS AND ALL KIND OF
CONCLUDE HERE AND WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. BUT
AS WE GO IN NOW AND WE LOOK AND
SEE THAT THE EXTRAORDINARY JOB
THAT OUR CULTURES AND IS IT.
ADAPTING TO THE SITUATION
BEFORE US. IS CONCERNED IS
CALIFORNIA OPENS UP. HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO PROTECT OUR
EMPLOYEES IN THE AND WHAT HOW
WE'VE SUCCESSFULLY. MINIMIZED
THE IMPACT ON OUR FARMS FROM
THIS COVERT NINETEEN AS
CALIFORNIA OPENS UP AND I KNOW
STATE A CALIFORNIA- SACRAMENTO
COUNTY- BEGINS. THEIR FACE TO I
BELIEVE BEGIN TOMORROW I
ACTUALLY FARMING VIEW COUNTY.
SO WE ARE A FEW DAYS AHEAD OF
AHEAD OF THEIR- BUT AS- OUR
EMPLOYEES LEAVE A VERY
CONTAINED- ISOLATED ENVIRONMENT
WE CAN CONTROL WHO COMES AND
GOES- AND NOW BEGIN TO
PARTICIPATE IN NORMAL
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE- THE
LIABILITIES OF WHAT IS IT
EFFORT A PULLEY. CONTACTS
COVERT NINETEEN OFF THE FARM
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
PROTECT OURSELVES AND OUR
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THAT IS GOING
TO BE A REALITY THEY WILL BE
MORE ACTIVE HE'S GOING OFF OFF
THE FARM AFTER WORK HOURS AS- A
CALIFORNIA OPENS UP DURING
THESE DIFFERENT PHASES SO
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT WE HAVE-
IN TERMS OF RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT WERE MADE-
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
COMMUNICATION BE ABLE TO HAVE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEM BUT THAT IS A CONCERN
GOING FORWARD THAT. THAT SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED I'LL SAY THIS IS
JUST AND RIGHT HERE AS WE LOOK
AT THE BUDGET BEFORE US AS WE
LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES BOTH NATIONALLY AND
STATEWIDE- IN TERMS OF BUDGET
IN THE EXPENSES WE HAD TO TAKE
TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS- IS.
THINGS WE LOOK AT THAT CAN
BRING ECONOMY BACK IN A BUDGET
BACK AROUND- IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENT. AND INVESTMENT IN
THE RECOVERY OF OUR ECONOMY
WILL EITHER BE CONSUMPTION LET.
ITS OPENING BACK UP OUR
RESTAURANTS ARE THEATERS. ARE
SPORTING EVENTS- ILLEGAL BE
EXPORT LED. SO WHAT WE
HOPEFULLY OUR TRADING PARTNERS
HALF OF WHAT WE PRODUCE IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIVE. PERCENT
20% OF WHAT WE PRODUCE. A IN
CALIFORNIA TO GO TO AN EXPORT
MARKET- SO. THAT WE EXPORT A
LOT OF GOODS WELL OUR NAY WELL
OUR PARTNERS STAY OPEN THE
EUROPEAN UNION OUR LARGEST
TRADING PARTNER THAN CANADA.
AND OF COURSE MEXICO. AND THEN
OF COURSE INVESTMENT. SOUL
PEOPLE INVESTING CALIFORNIA AS
WE BEGIN THIS RECOVERY. AND OF
COURSE AGRICULTURE WE'RE PROUD
TO SAY STANDS READY. TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL THREE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF
OUR EXPORT. AND OUR OWN
PERSONAL INVESTMENT THAT WE
MAKE. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKING CALIFORNIA TO GROW OUR
BUSINESSES. SO THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU. AND CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER JOHANNSEN I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS PLEASE STICK AROUND CA
BECAUSE WILL ASK QUESTIONS BUT
WE DIDN'T WANT TO. SPEND THE
NEXT HOUR ASKING YOU QUESTIONS
AND NOT LEAVE ENOUGH TIME FOR
EVERYONE ELSE WHO ALSO IS-
INVITED- PRESENTS WILL GO
THROUGH THE- PANELISTS BEFORE
WE THEN. APPROACH THE
QUESTIONS. AT THIS POINT I'M
GOING TO SPEAK TO THE PHONE
MODERATOR. WHO I AM GOING TO
ASK TO PUT ON THE LINE. SERRA
FLOCKS WHO IS THE POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION THANK YOU
PHONE MODERATOR. AIRLINE US
OPEN. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GOOD MORNING MISS FOX THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT THE INVITATION AND FOR ALL
THE HELP FROM YOUR STAFF- MY
NAME IS SERRA FLOCKS AND FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. WE REPRESENT TWO
MILLION UNION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA THOSE MEMBERS WORK
IN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR AND ACROSS MULTIPLE
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING THE
BUILDING TRADES. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE WERE SENT BY
STAFF BUT I WANTED TO ACTUALLY
START WITH- WAS ABOUT THE
WESTERN STATE PACKED AND
WHETHER IT'S LANDING STABILITY.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE WESTERN
STATES PACKED IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND A REALLY GREAT
MODEL BUSINESSES ACROSS STATE
BOUNDARIES WHICH MEANS THAT
UNIONS DO. WE HAVE WESTERN
STATE COUNCILS THAT ARE MORE
THAN JUST CALIFORNIA SO HAVING
COORDINATION WITH NEIGHBORING
STATES MAKES IT EASIER TO BE.
RE OPENING IT ALSO PROVIDES A
MODEL FOR FUTURE COLLABORATION
IN TERMS THAT FOR EXAMPLE PAUL
PURCHASING OF MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. WERE
JUDGED ONGOING COLLABORATIONS
SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SPEAK AT
THIS HEARING AND- VERY
HEARTENED BY THE WORK THE
GOVERNOR'S ARE DOING IN TERMS
OF THE WESTERN STATES. SO WE'RE
GOING ON TO THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT THE PANDEMIC AND THAT THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS ON OUR OUR
MEMBERS. WE'VE BEEN AFFECTED IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS FIRST OF
COURSE HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
PANDEMIC FROM THE BEGINNING AND
HAVE BEEN VERY DISHEARTENED BY
THE LACK OF PP THE LACK OF A
STOCKPILE HAVING EXPIRED AND
NINETY FIVE MASK. HAVING TO
FASHION THEIR OWN MASS- AND
REACHING MANY OF THEM CONTRACT
ILLNESS AND UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY TO DO TO IT- WE'RE
VERY HEARTENED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
TO HELP WORKERS COMP
PRESUMPTION- BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION FOR. ALL
OF THE WORKERS ON THE FRONT
LINE ESPECIALLY HEALTHCARE
WORKERS- WE ALSO REPRESENT
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS-
SEARCHES IN GROCERY FOOD
SERVICE. BACK CHILD CARE
NURSING HOMES WHICH ARE REALLY.
I WOULD SAY MORE THAN A CENTURY
WORKERS THE REALLY ARE
SACRIFICIAL WORKERS THERE THE
ONE TO GO TO WORK AND JUST
DELIVER THE FOOD AND STOCK THE
GROCERY STORE SHELVES SO THAT
ALL OF US CAN SHELTER IN PLACE
THESE ARE OFTEN WORKERS THAT
ARE THE LOWEST PAID. WITH NO
BENEFITS LACKING PP FACING
RETALIATION FOR SPEAKING UP
SOME OF THEM AREN'T EVEN
WORKERS THEY'VE BEEN MIS
CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS- AND JUST DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THE RIGHT EVEN TO
HAVE. PP PROVIDED BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS- AND SO. ARE REALLY
THE SUFFERING- AND EXPOSING A
LOT OF DAY INEQUITIES THAT ARE
BUILT INTO OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM.
IN TERMS OF WORKERS WHO ARE
DEEMED NONESSENTIAL DAY ARE
FACING THEIR OWN WORLD OF
ECONOMIC HER AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF FOR
FURLOUGHED- ARE STRUGGLING TO
GET UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE- AN
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- A LOT OF
THE MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING TO GET
UNEMPLOYMENTINSURANCE LIKELY
NOW HAVE THE KEY WAY- BUT
REALLY ARE OURS ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO SURVIVE.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
ECONOMY TO RE OPEN AND BE
SEEING IN SECURITY OF KNOWING
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AS THE
ECONOMY VERY SLOWLY WE OPEN
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE LEARNING
THAT THE OPENING MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE A LOT MORE CHALLENGING THAN.
THE ORIGINAL LOCKED DOWN- AND I
THINK THE BUDGET THAT BUDGET
SUB FOR HEARINGS YESTERDAY
SHOWED HOW TRULY STRAINED OUR
SAFETY NET IS- AND HOW NEGLECT
HAS REALLY LACKED IN A PLACE
WHERE IT'S NOT IN A POSITION TO
RESPOND TO A MAJOR ECONOMIC
CRISIS ARE. SO I WOULD SAY THAT
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT MAJOR
REFORMS TO OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM SUCH AS
RAISING THE TAXABLE WAGE PAGE
INCREASING THE LEVEL OF
BENEFITS MAKING SURE WE HAVE
SOME STUDY FUNDING SO THE NEXT
TIME THAT HIT WE DON'T HAVE TO
BORROW EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
EXPANDING THE WORKS YEAR
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
WORKERS CAN. ENACTED TO THEIR
JOBS AND THAT THE PARTIAL. YOU
WHY PROGRAM. TO GO ON TO BE
OPENING AND OF OUR- AROUND RE
OPEN. I THINK THERE IS THERE'S
THREE AL. AND FIRST ONE AND THE
ONE THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE RIGHT
NOW MOST CONCERNED ABOUT. IS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF BOTH
WORKERS AND CUSTOMERS AS WE
START TO SEE BUSINESS RE
OPENED- AND SO I THINK. OUR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
ENFORCEABLE OPEN GUIDELINES DAD.
TO PROTECT WORKERS AND HOUSE.
AND GENERALLY WHEN WE COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE WE ASK FOR
THINGS- LAWS THAT IT BE THREE
SENATE MINIMUM LIKE THE MINIMUM
WAGE MINIMUM NUMBER EXPECT
CLEAT SO WE CAN START TO FLOOR.
THAT WE CAN BAND HAVE OTHER
EMPLOYERS GO UP FROM. IN TERMS
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
A FLOOR IS NOT A KNOCKED THAT
HAVE TO BE THE GOLD. BECAUSE
WORKERS LIFE AND- PUBLIC LIVES
ARE AT RISK WE CAN'T. JUST WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO. WITH NO HAVING.
THAT SCIENTIFIC. BASED YEAH
APPROPRIATE THEN FLED TO THE
SITUATION. AND ALSO WE'RE GOING
TO THE A CON AT RISK BECAUSE IF
HAVE THIS WAVE AND HALF TO
WREAK. IT STONE GONNA DEPEND
THAT THE REST. SO IN TERMS OF
HAVING IT STANDARD WE REALLY
NEED TO MAY SURE THE CALLOW HAS
ALL THE- INSPECTORS THAT THEY
NEED. AT THAT DOES A- OFFER
HAVE THE POWER PP WE CAN X. OUR-
STATE WORKERS TO IN AND IT'S
DANGER WORK. IT DATA HAVE THE
PROTECTION YOU NEED KEEP UP
SAFE ALONG THOSE LINES WE NEED
BUT PROTECT. AS WE OPEN FOR
WORKERS WHO WANT TO REFUSE
UNSAFE WORK OR REFUSE WERE
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT AND SO WAY
AND MANY OF OUR- ARE AND YOU
KNOW COME FROM. CAN'T JUSTIFY.
THEY HAVE ASKED MY DAD. OTHER
ON CAN. WE NEED TO MAKE THAT
EVEN IF WORK PLACES ARE SAFE IF
IT DOES WRKERS FEEL LIKE.
CAN'T GO TO WAR. THAT DAY HAVE
A TO KEEP THEIR ON. INSURANCE
OR HAVE OTHER KINDS JUST. BACK
AT ME TO NEXT POINT WHERE IT'S
MAKING SURE. WE HAVE AN
ADEQUATE NET TO GET WORKERS.
THROUGH THE BE OPEN. WINDOWS
THIS IS GONNA BE. FLOWER CON
SAY THAT IT'S GOING TO BE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO JUST. BRING BACK
TO OUR PRE PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS
OF EMPLOYMENT AND- ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY- SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE INCOME SUPPORT
IN PLACE TO WORKERS SO THEY CAN
GET THROUGH THIS- THAT AGAIN
YOU Y. BENEFITS- SOME MORE AND
INCREASE CASH GRANTS FOR.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHICH
ARE LOCKED OUT OF BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL AID PROGRAMS AND
THEN AGAIN THE WORK SHARE
PROGRAMS AND THE U. Y. SO. THE
WAY FOR EMPLOYERS TO KEEP
WORKERS ON THE JOB MAYBE NOT AT
FULL SALARY BUT THAT THERE MADE
WHOLE AGAIN. THAT INCLUDES
FIGURING OUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
KEEP WORKERS' EITHER ON THEIR
HEALTH COVERAGE OR HAVE
INCREASED SUBSIDIES SO THAT
THEY CAN KEEP HELL HEALTH
COVERAGE OR EXPAND. ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM DURING
A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IS
THE WORST TIME TO TAKE WAY
PEOPLE HEALTH BENEFITS. ALL WHY
WOULD THAT WE WASTE KEEP WORKER
CONNECTED THEIR JOB IF WANT TO
BE ABLE TO. HAVE CONNIE BACK IN
THE BACK TO WAY AND SO WE HAD
WE START RIO. THE BUSINESS ARE
BACK TO PRODUCTIVITY AND WERE
REALLY ABLE TO JUMP START THE
ECONOMY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE RECALL AND ATTENTION
PROTECTIONS. THAT WORKERS STAY
CONNECTED TO THEIR JOBS AND
THAT THE MOST EXPERIENCED AND
SKILLED WORKERS ARE CALLED
BACK- AN EMPLOYER STATE ON
TRAINING COSTS. AND WORKERS ARE
BACK AT THE SAME CHAO SO THEY
CAN TURN AROUND AND WE AND THAT
MONEY IN THE ECONOMY. AND THEN
ALSO I THINK WE NEED TO START
RE OPENING WITH AN EYE TO THE
ECONOMY THAT WE WANT TO BUILD
AN ECONOMY THAT PERHAPS. MORE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN A PANDEMIC OR A
NATURAL DISASTER OR- AND
ECONOMIC RECESSION WHICH WE HAD
A FEELING WITH COMING IT JUST
CAME A LOT SOONER AND MORE
DRASTICALLY THAN EXPECTED- SO
FIRST. I THINK THE BEST IN ITS
BACK CONDIMENTS THAT 42% OF
JOBS THAT ARE LOCKED OR NOT
COMING BACK. AND SO WHERE CAN
WE- TAKE PEOPLE AND PT THEM
WHAT KIND OF NEW JOBS DO WE
NEED HOW DO WE REACH TRAIN AND
DEPLOY WORKERS INTO THE SECTOR
AND MAKE SURE THAT. THE WAGES
ARE AT A LEVEL THAT MAKE THEM
ATTRACTIVE- DO WE NEED TO HAVE
A PUBLIC HEALTH OR SANITATION
CORPS. DO WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SHORING UP THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY THE CARE INDUSTRY IN
TERMS OF CHILD ELDER NURSING
HOME CARE- AND HOW DO WE DO
THAT AND SO. I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AS WE RE OPEN AND
START TO SEE WHAT THE HOLD THAT
OUR ECONOMY ARE. THAT WE CAN
THINK ABOUT. WHERE IS OUR TAX
DOLLARS BEST INVESTED- TO START
EATING. DEVELOPMENT IN CERTAIN
AREAS WHERE DO WE NEED TO BE
TRAINING- HOW DO WE DEPLOY OUR
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE EACH
BUILDING AND RE OPENING THE
ECONOMY IN A WAY THAT IS GOOD
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT
ADDRESSES OUR INCOME INEQUALITY.
ISSUES AND ALSO DOUBLES AS A
ECONOMY. AND SO JUST AGAIN
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING ON THIS ISSUE AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AFTER
THE OTHER PANEL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS FLOCKS THAT- THOSE A
SUBSTANTIVE- PRESENTATION AND-
CERTAINLY RAISE A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH AS WE
WANT TO. REBOUND IN SOME FORM
FROM- FROM THIS RECESSION
NEARING GREAT DEPRESSION LEVELS
IMPACTS ON LABOR. IN CALIFORNIA
AND TOUCHING ALMOST EVERY
PERSON WHO WORKS IN OUR STATE.
NEXT I WILL SPEAK TO DIRECTLY
TO THE PHONE MODERATOR. WHO IF
YOU COULD PLEASE HELP ME- DID
INVITE LANCE HE STANDS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. THE CAROLINAS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR ON DURING
THIS YOU KNOW VERY IMPACTFUL
PANDEMIC THAT WERE THAT WERE
TAKING THAT OCCURS WE WANT TO
START WITH A QUOTE. I'M MIKE
TYSON HE SAID EVERYONE HAS A
PLAN AND YOU'RE PUT IN THE
MOUTH. AND I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THE THIS. REGARD CREDIT BY
IN A PUNCH IN THE MOUTH BECAUSE
WE ALL HAD TO. BE FORCED TO A
DE TO A NEW LAW. AND WHEN I SAY
ALL A US COMING PER. THAT
MATTER HOW THEY ARE. A SUICIDE
AND THE WAY YEAH IT'S A-
BUSINESS OWNER IS A YOUR
RETAILER WE'RE HERE LATER. YEAH
WE ARE ALL IN. AND JUST QUICKLY
AN ATTIC. CMJ STAFF ON FRIDAY
MARCH THIRD. SO I'M JUST TO
HAVE A- REMOTE WORK SESSION
FROM ALL HAS A TRIAL RUN TO SEE.
WHAT THE CHALLENGE MIGHT BE IN
THAT WE ARE A POOR CASE MAY
HAVE TO CHILDREN PLACE A MOBILE
YOUR COME MONDAY MORNING. WE
HAD INDICATES OF OUR STAFF TO A-
WHOLE AND REMOTE WE DONE THAT
FOR WEEKS. RATES ABOUT AMONG
THE SECTORS AND YOU KNOW NOT
SURPRISINGLY BASIL HEARD
ALREADY. SERVICE SECTOR IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPACTED IN WITHIN
THE SERVICE SECTOR LEISURE AND
HOSPITALITY IS DOWN FORTY FOUR
PERCENT. AND SERVICE SECTORS
DOWN 23% ALMOST TWENTY FOUR
THAT YET MANUFACTURING DOWN 90%
AND I WANT TO FOCUS MUCH OF MY
COMMENT ON. THAT THAT NOTION
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT IN OUR
SECTOR IS SO LOW AND MAYBE GIVE
SOME. AND AS TO WHY AND IT GOES
BACK TO THAT CHILDREN PLACE
ORDER ON MARCH SIXTEENTH. FIRST
CALL THAT WE RECEIVED WORD FROM
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAD SUPPLY
CHAIN IN PROCESS. THEY HAD A
HOT DEAL WILL ACROSS THE BILL
THEY HAD GLASS BEING ROLLED
OUT. IN OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU
JUST CAN'T TURN OFF. EXTREME
FACILITY. SO WE HAD TO ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIACY OF THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER. AND WE FOUND THAT
MANY OF THE MAIN CHARACTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LINKS TO THE
ARTICLE IT THE STATURE SUPPLY
CHAIN OF THE COUNTRY. AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT MANY OF US RAIL
SALE BUT IT WASN'T. THE ABILITY
TO STAY OPEN THAT WAS IMPORTANT
WAS HOW WE WERE ABLE TO STAY
OPEN. AND THE WAY WE HAVE TO DO
SAYS WE IMMEDIATELY NOTIFIED
OUR MEMBERSHIP. TO ADOPT SOCIAL
DISTANCE SEEN IN HIS HYGIENE
AND ALL OF THE FACILITIES-
WHICH THEY DID. AND THEY DID IT
IMMEDIATELY THEY WERE ABLE TO
STAY OPEN AND HAVE HAD.
EXCEEDINGLY LOW OCCURRENCES OF
THE VIRUS THAT AMONG ALL
WORKFORCE WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WORKS ACTUALLY QUITE PROUD
OF BUT THE BOTTOM EVERY CASE
MANY FACTS FACILITY THERE ARE
TWO BEING HERE. OFF A- ALONG
THE WAY WHERE EMPLOYEES NEED TO
BE AT LEAST SIXTY OR CLOSER.
AND HAVING TO ADAPT THOSE.
ACTIVITIES BANNED THAT IT
DIFFICULT BUT SOMETHING THAT
BEEN CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO DO. SO THAT WAS PHASE
ONE. FOR US- AND THEN FACE TO
WAS RESPONDING TO THE- THE
PERHAPS IN THAT FOR IN THE
REGIONAL ORDERS WERE IN.
ADDITION TO FIVE MILES YOU
CAN'T CHIU VASTLY DIFFERENT.
PROTOCOLS BY A LOCAL
JURISDICTION ABOUT WHAT CAN AND
CANNOT OCCUR WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION. THE WILD THE
MANUFACTURED SECTOR CONTINUE TO
RELY UPON THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. STATUS WAS NOT
ALWAYS RECOGNIZE OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE HAD A SITUATION
WHERE MANUFACTURERS- IN ONE
AREA WE'RE NOT ABLE TO OPERATE-
OTHER MANUFACTURES. IT PERHAPS
EVEN AT A NEIGHBORING AREA. AND
THAT WAS A CHALLENGE AND THEN I
THINK WHEN THE WESTERN PACKED
CHAMBER WHICH IS REALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THE START. SELECT
HEARING. OUR COUNTERPARTS IN
OREGON WASHINGTON AND CAL.
INCLUDING THE CHAMBERS AND
FACTS IN RETAIL REST WE ALL GO
TOGETHER IMMEDIATELY YEAH CALL
AND WE- ESTABLISHED A PRO.
AMONG THEN REACHED TO EACH OF
THE GOVERNOR'S IN THOSE. AT THE
TIME THREE STATES. TO REALLY.
THE FACT THAT THE ECONOMY. IS
LOW THE- RE. ECONOMIES NATIONAL
INFECTED. IS GLOBAL IT AND WE
IN A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT WERE
ABLE TO. SOME CAUSE CONCERT
ABOUT FOR AND WE WERE VERY.
IMPRESSED AND PLEASED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKEN AT YOU KNOW
CRITICAL PERHAPS UNPRECEDENTED
STEP. LOOKING FOR WAYS TING
COURTNEY NOR AND ORGANIZE
THEMSELVES IN A REGIONAL
ASPECTS SHOULD BE A PART OF
THAT EFFORT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. BUT THERE PHASE WAS
THE TO IDENTIFY SUPPLY. THAT'S
TO GET OPERATE. AND WE HAVE
LIKE THE PART STUNT SURVEYED
ARE MY- AND THROUGHOUT THE
CRISIS THE MAIN. SECTOR CAL
ANYWAYS. ANYWHERE BETWEEN
SEVENTY AND 75% CAPACITY. AND
AGAIN THAT'S CRITICAL IN THOSE
UNEMPLOYMENT FIGURES THAT I
MENTIONED JUST A BIT AGO. AND
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP
THINGS GOING TO KEEP THINGS
MOVING- WHICH HAS BEEN. QUITE
HELPFUL. THE TIED INTO THAT IS
OUR ABILITY TO KEEP THE WORKERS
EMPLOYED BUT ALSO ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT HOURS AND OUTPUT IS HAVE
THE CLIENT AND WE HAVE
APPROACHED. THE LABOR AGENCY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO SEE IF
THERE ARE WAYS TO. GET AT LEAST
IN THE NEAR TERM HAVE A FORM
SOME OF THE WORK SHARE
PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THEY
QUESTIONS THAT WERE GETTING
FROM OUR MEMBERS WAS. HOW CAN
WE KEEP OUR EMPLOYEES BENEFITS
GOING EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NOT
EITHER AT WORK OR ABLE TO WORK
AND EVERYTHING LED TO THE WORK
YOUR PROGRAM IS TRYING TO. FIND
A WAY TO ACKNOWLEDGE AT LEAST
IN A CRISIS MODE. DAD SOME
ACCOMMODATIONS IN THAT SPACE
WOULD WOULD AND SHOULD BE IN
ORDER IT AFTER ALL THE
DESTRUCTION OF LOSING WHAT
HEALTH BENEFITS AND HEALTH
CRISIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
CHALLENGING ASPECT. OF ALL FOR
BOTH THE EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES. SO HAPPY TO SEE
THAT- DIRECTOR SUE. ENGAGE AS
CONVERSATIONS WITH US AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT A COOKING. UP. TO
ADVANCE FOR THE FUTURE. THANK
WITH THAT I'M GONNA. LOOK AT
THE LAST QUESTION WHICH IS FOR.
WHAT WOULD YOUR TODAY LIKE THIS
IT UP FOR ME FOR IN REAL. AND
ECONOMY. I THINK WE WE'VE ALL
EVERYONE THE HERE FROM IS. THAT
TAKEN THEIR- AND DURING THE
CRISIS. BUT IT'S THE ABILITY
WHEN WE COME OUT AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS CLEAR.
CONSISTENT AND IN FACT BEGIN
ABEL'S AND ECONOMIC RE OPENING
OR RECOVERING HER HOWEVER WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT. RATHER THAN
USING THE OLD RULES ARE APPLIED
TO THE NEW SITUATION BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT THOSE WILL BE
AT THE MAYBELLINE- AS AS ARE
NECESSARY. IN PART OF THAT IS
LOOKING AT THE LIABILITY WHILE
WE RE OPEN. BECAUSE IT'S THE
OLD PHRASE TO THEM BUT I AM
REMINDED OF THE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
DARNED IF YOU DO IN YOUR GARDEN
DELVED. BUT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER IN TRYING TO RE OPEN
THE ECONOMY'S GONNA TAKE
COOPERATION AMONG ALL OF US.
WHETHER YOUR EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE. A CIVIC LEADER. SUCH
AS YOURSELVES. WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER AND NOW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS. WHAT CAN
ENABLE ECONOMY TO REAL BECAUSE
IT IS NOT LIKE A LIGHT SWITCH.
ONE DOESN'T TURN OFF THE CAR ME
AND WANTED TO TURN ON ECONOMY
IT IS A- ACCESS IT IS YEAH YEAH.
A LOT OF PLAYER A LOT. INPUT
YOUR- TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT CMJ
IN OUR MEMBERS. ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH. EVERYONE
INVOLVED LOCAL REGIONAL.
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL AS THOSE
CASES- ARE NECESSARY- TOOK TO
REOPEN ECONOMY. BUT WE JUST
CAN'T JOLTED OPEN AND SOMEONE
WOULD YOU CAN'T JONES TO CLOSE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION AND
PART OF THAT SOLUTION. AND THAT
YOU'RE HERE FROM SOME
RETAILERS- SHORTLY- FARMERS
GROW IT WE MAKE IT AND THEY
SELL IT AND IT'S REALLY QUITE
THAT SIMPLE AND WE ARE AN ECO
SYSTEM. AMONG OURSELVES AS A
GROUP AND ONE THAT I'M- HAPPY
AND PROUD TO BE PART OF AND-
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. AT LEAST GREATLY
APPRECIATED. BY OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR MEMBERSHIP
AND I WILL STAND BY AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO A DIALOGUE OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
LATER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE YOU MISS
HASTINGS FOR JOINT US. PHONE
MODERATOR I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE RACHEL MICHELIN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AT THIS
POINT. TELL YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU-
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDED A
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS AND TODAY
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT WE
OPENING AND YOU KNOW I WHEN I
GET BACK ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT LANCE HAD TALKED ABOUT I
WILL SAY I ALWAYS LOOK FOR THE
POSITIVE. AND I THINK ONE OF
THE POSITIVE ASPECTS OF GOING
THROUGH THE LAST FEW WEEKS HAD
AND AT THE COLLABORATION OF MAN
MANY DIFFERENT CHORDS I LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT WITHIN THE
WESTERN REGION I WITH THE
COLLECTIVE GOAL NUMBER ONE
PROTECTING OUR FORTY PROTECTING
OUR CONSUMERS PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
THEN ALSO TRYING TO WORK
TOGETHER ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE APPRECIATE
HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS TEAM
HILL AYE THOSE HIGHER WE ARE
TRYING TO HELP OPEN UP THE
ACCOUNT. THAT WE DO IT BUT FONG
ASSEMBLY AND SAFELY SO THAT WE
CAN SEE CALIFORNIA RETURNED TO
THE ECONOMIC AND ECSTATIC THAT
WE HAD PRIOR TO THAT COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS POSITION
EXPECT INTERESTING COUPLE.
BECAUSE MY COMPANY. WHAT ABOUT
AND TALKING IN THE BACK IT AS
BEING EXPENSE AND NONESSENTIAL
LIMITS BURST HEY SOME OF OUR
MEMBER WERE THE FACT. THEY OPEN
BE WRAPPED. ALL OF RETAIL PRICE
YOUR BAR BIG BY. STORES YOU'RE
NOT DEPARTMENT STORE BRANDS. HE
REGIONAL STORES. THAT RETAILERS
THAT MAKE THAT THE BACKBONE ARE
STAY AT MY HOUSE FOR BECAUSE
THE NOT BUT- AND WOMEN FIRST
CAME. IN A LOT OF TIME WORKING
THE GOVERNOR OFFICE WHEN HE
CAME TO PUT AGAIN THE THANK YOU
PRODUCT. ACT ARE. AND PUT OUR
CONSUME. YOU KNOW THE REALLY
WHY THEY I BY BUT WRITTEN WE
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH TIME WE- WORKED VERY. WITH
A PART OF PUBLIC AT THE OFF.
AND WE REALLY ONE TO MAKE WE
WERE DOING AB. WE COULD KEEP.
THE SPREAD OF THE NINETEEN. AND
MANY OF MY COMPANIES TO. WERE
NOT BEING TO. AND WHO WERE KIND
OF IN THAT NOT. BASKET DECIDE
TO BACK BACK AND IN CASES THEY
SWITCH OVER TO. CREATING FAKE.
A NINE MEMBER COMPANIES BURKE
FIRST ON MY DON'T NAY. KP HOW.
I THINK THE RETAIL. REALLY STEP
BACK TO HELP AT THE INITIAL
TIME WITH THE KOBE. AND THEN
THE CAT. AND WE'VE BEEN LOOKING.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE. FOR ME BE THE
WE ARE A TO YOU THAT BACK
PRACTICE. THAT WE WERE FROM OUR
MEMBERS THAT HAVE OPEN. AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE SHARE THE THAT
PRACTICES WITH OUR- WHO ARE NOW
IN THE PROCESS OPENING TODAY.
AND WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR STATE
COVERING LEARNED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE THAT SIGNAGE SOCIAL
DISTANCE SAID CONSUMERS HOW TO
REALLY EDUCATE CONSUMERS WHEN
THEY COME INTO A RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENT. WE'VE REALLY
BEEN ABLE TO UTILIZE BACK AND
NOT ONLY ARE WE DID NOT FOR OUR
MEMBERS HE STARTED AN OUTREACH
PROGRAM. AND RECENTLY WHERE WE
ARE WORKING ACROSS THE STATE
WITH LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
TO EDUCATE PARTICULAR ARE
INDEPENDENTLY CALORIE. SO THAT
WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO OPEN THEY
CAN REALLY HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING. BECAUSE WE REALIZE
THAT ONE OF MY BIGGEST FEAR TO
BACK. MY WE'RE SEEING SIGNED
WITH THE NATIONAL NEWS AND YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO LEAD TIME. THE
NATIONAL RETAILERS BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC. I DON'T THINK IN
CALIFORNIA WILL TRULY
UNDERSTAND. THE IMPACT. WHAT
WILL HAVE ARE INDEPENDENT MALL.
BOB SMALL BUSINESSES THE STATE.
SO IT THAT WE CHARACTER CA AND
WORKED EVERY WE- EDUCATED
PREPARE INDEPENDENT RETAILERS.
THAT THEY WILL BE TO HOW. YOU
KNOW HIT THE GROUND RUNNING BE
ABLE TO BREAK CONSUMERS. THEY
GOT SOME OF THAT THE REVENUE
THEY HAVE MY- WAY BACK THEIR
EMPLOYEES. AND WILL HE BE BACK
ADULT CONTRIBUTOR TO THEIR
LOCAL ECONOMIES THAT THEY WERE
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE THEME.
RELATED THE PANDEMIC I WILL
STAY WITH YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW I
JUST EVERY DAY I REALIZE
ANALYSIS OF. LOCAL ORDINANCES
RIGHT NOW RECORD FIVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT LOCAL ORDINANCES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT CAN BE KIND
OF CHALLENGING WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH. AND SUCH A BIG
STATE AND WHEN WITHIN A COUNTY
THE CITY MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
MORTGAGES AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE AND IT'S ONE THAT WE'RE
HAVING A CHALLENGE WET. AND
THAT THE ISSUE OF MANDATORY
BASED ARMORY. AND WE HAVE
CERTAIN. AND CITIES AND- OF
MANDATED THEY HAVE ABOUT. ARE A
HUNDRED PER THE POOR OUT. ABOUT
THE- IN MANY CASES ARE NOT
COMPANY ARE STEP. FACE COVER
BECAUSE- AS THEY WALK IN SHE
WAS. TO MAKE WE'RE PROTECTING
EVERY. IN THAT IT THAT BUSH MET.
WHAT WE HAVE IN THE RIGHT OF
WAY IN A DIFFERENT ARE. WHERE
SPEAK OF BY AGAINST SALES
ASSOCIATE. WHEN IT COMES TO US
WORKING FAKE COVERING AT
RECENTLY AT SEVEN. AND AREA WE
A WELL HE HE WAS. PHYSICALLY IF.
TRYIG TO AND THE MAY. AND BIG
CORRECT WE HAD ENOUGH THOUSAND.
YOU'LL HAVE AN HOLD ON THEM. IN
THIS. AND I SELL AT DON'T SEE
IT WOULD BUT HELP I'M TRYING
TO. THE STATE COVERING. ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST ISSUE HAS BAD THAT
WHILE WE WANT AND FOR THE
ORDINANCE THERE. OUR SALES
ASSOCIATES ARMED ARE NOT MINE
FOR. AND INSTANTIATED RKO BUT
YEAR ARE BEING. HOST MILEY FOR
NOW ENFORCING A ORDINANCE. THAT
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE- THAT
WERE RIGHT NOW IN IT COMES TO
FIVE HYDE DIFFERENT WORD AND
BOB THIS STATE. WE TO. BUT IT'S
VERY CHEN. WHEN HE CAN'T WORK
WORKING ON THIS DAY PAGE WHEN
IT TO WILL FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
PROTECT. THE STATE OF OUR FORTY
AND OUR CAN. NOT ONLY NOW FROM
THE COLD DEAD FOR THE BUYER.
BUT NOW FROM BY BECAUSE THEIR
TO DO RIGHT THING. WE HAVE
THINGS LIKE IN KERN. FINANCIAL
I. YOU KNOW WE IN SOME CASES
THE WE DO RENT SO WANT TO YOU
CAN COMING NEXT. THE BACK THEN
WE TO THE MORE BY. BUT THOSE
ARE SOME THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN. WEIGHING HAVE A ON. OUR
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES HOW YEAH.
BUT YOU CAN. ADD MORE MORE
POWER OPENING RETAIL OPEN. AND
SHOP MALLS. THAT THE NEED
REALLY NEED THIS OUT AT DATE
WHY AT. TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO
WITH. THE ISSUE BATES COVERING.
I OTHER ISSUES WE DEAL WITH
WITH THE OPENING I THINK I'M
CITY AND CAL TO BEND VERY HOW.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS
BETTER X. HELPFUL WE HAVE WORK
TOGETHER WE I WORKED WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN OTHER STATE ARE
BACKED PRACTICE DAYS. AND
POLITICALLY IN WESTERN. SO THAT
WE REALLY DO I'VE SHARED MY
OPENING PLANNED WATCH JANET
BECAUSE- THEY'VE BEAR. WE'VE
INCORPORATED OF THOSE. YOU KNOW
OUR FIRST AND- THING I SAY TO
MY MOM COMPANY IS BY DO YOU THE
DISCUSSION BEEN. BUT AND THE
THAT IT WILL LEAVE ON THE RIGHT.
OF THE- TO ENSURE THAT. OF OUR
CONSUMER. BECAUSE IT WE DON'T
THAT THE- WILL NOT COME BACK AT
YOU STORE. IT WOULD YOU SAY
THAT WHY CURBSIDE ONLINE. AND
HELP GET SEVEN CASES. AND IT IS
NOT. EQUAL THE AMOUNT OF. THAT
HELP BRING THEN WENT FOR CANAL
COME INTO BE CAL. MATT. AND THE-
IS THAT ARE. YOU KNOW COUNTY
THE NUMBER FOR. AND WE HAD P.
E. R. AFRAID ALL OF THAT COULD
YOU BAR. RETAILER HAVE AN IT PP
WILL WORK WITH THE STATE ON
ACTUALLY MAKING SURE THAT THEY
ACCESS TO BACK. ONE OF MY BIG.
CONCERN WHAT I'M TO WORK ON I
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE IS
MATURING THAT ARE SMALL BUT-
HAVE ACCESS THE P. T. I NEED.
TO GET THEM POURTANT. A
PARTICULAR. AND IT RETAILERS
ACROSS STATE THAT THEY THAT
THAT THAT IF WE CAN GET FOR
FREE FOR THEM WOULD BE GREAT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
WORK CAP THAT SOME OF LARGER
RETAILERS HAVE AND BY WHAT IN
THIS TOGETHER SAID OF MY LARGER
RETAIL WHO HAVE BEEN OPEN.
THEY'RE WORKING WITH ME TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THE SMALLER
RETAILERS HAVE ACCESS TO. THAT
PROTECTIVE COVERING THEY NEED
TO PROTECT OUR EMPLOYEES AND OP
THE PROTECTOR CONSUMERS. I
THINK RETAILERS ARE. ARE
EXCITED TO BE OPENING BACK UP
IN CALIFORNIA THOSE THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN OPEN FOR THE PAST
EIGHT WEEKS THEY'RE PUTTING A
LOT OF TIME A LOT OF EFFORT
INTO ENSURING THAT. THEIR
EMPLOYEES THEIR SPACE INSURING
THAT THEIR CONSUMERS OUR STATE
ENSURING THAT THE EXPERIENCE.
OF THEIR I'M DEFINITELY BE
CHANGES WHEN YOU WALK INTO A
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENT. AND
LEADING WHIMS MAY NOT BE OPEN
AND YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE
RETURNS RIGHT AWAY. YOU MAY NOT
BE AS- I HAD MATCH AT MANY AT.
DIFFERENT THINGS ON THE SALES
FLOOR AS YOU DID. I IN ISSUE I
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
OF GOD THE CRITICALLY I ALLEGED
I EIGHT WORKED THAT I. ARE NOT.
AND WHERE HAVE AND SAN AND ADDS
LEAD YOU LOOK FOR TO ONE OF THE
WE AREN'T AGAIN MY LARGER
MEMBERS ARE YOU DELAY BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE SMALLER
MEMBERS DO THAT WHILE IS RIGHT
THEY GIVE THERE'S A LESSON
LEARNED FROM THAT IT IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING EIGHTY. AT
OUR WEBSITE PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO ONLINE SALES
AND OUR HOPE IS THAT IF
SOMETHING DOES HAPPEN AGAIN IN
THE FALL WHICH- HEARING ARE
MA'AM. YEAH WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE LEARNED THAT
WE- EVERYTHING. I'M BECAUSE
THAT AND PASS YOU GET BACK AND-
BUT ON THE BUSINESS LOADER
PERSON THE MP ON THE COUNTY TAX
REVENUE. RETALIX THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
TODAY THE STATE'S ECONOMY WHERE
ONE QUARTER AND EMPLOYMENT FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS GONNA BE A BIG HEAD. AND
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO TRY TO HELP ALL RETAILERS
LARGE AND SMALL. WHETHER THEY
DORM WE'RE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH HE INNOVATIVE WAYS TO DO
TRAINING STATE HE THAT WE HAVE.
THE TRAIN ON THE STATE PRODUCT
THAT ARE HELD BY THE TO PUT OUT
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE ENSURE.
GET OUT WE IN CAL AT AND WE
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WITH ALL
OF OUR OUR- ARE KIDS. IN
PARTICULAR THE LARGER. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHER
ISSUE PERTAINING TO REALLY
BEING WE CALIBEX DRIVING IN THE
STATE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR INTEREST IN
A RETAIL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES THAT WE CONTINUE. TO
MOVE FORWARD TO THAT. ARMONK
VERY MUCH MISS MISS I WILL NOW
ASK THE PHONE GREATER TO INVITE
MATTHEW SUTTON SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND PUBLIC POLICY OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION TO JOIN THE PANEL.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M IT AIRED
MEMBERS THANK YOU CAN MUCH NOT
THAT IN CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE YOUR
HOLDEN HEARING APPRECIATE YOU
END UP WRITING A TO BE A PART
OF IT- WHERE THEY WAITED
RESTAURANTS XIN REPRESENTING
RESTAURANT THE BALL. ALL TYPES-
MOST OF OUR RESTAURANT BASED
ARE THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTAURANT THAT YOU HAVE IN
YOUR DISTRICT. SO THIS OBVIOUS
I THINK FOR EACH OF SPEAKER SO
FAR AND FRIENDS ON THE PANEL-
IT IT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY UNCHARTERED
TERRITORY TO SAY THE LEAST- YOU
KNOW WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT THE
BEGINNING. OF THE WAY THINGS.
CAME TOGETHER IN MARCH YOU KNOW
FOR THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY WE
HAD. THE WORLD'S COMPLETELY
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE UNDER US
IN IN A SHORT FOUR DAY PERIOD.
I'M SORRY MR KERRY ABLE TO HEAR
ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU IF YOU CAN
SPEAK GOOD. YES THANK YOU SO
IT'S LOOKING BACK YOU KNOW I
THINK RESTAURANTS WERE AMONG
THE FIRST IF NOT THE FIRST TO
BE MANDATED- IT SHUT DOWN MOST
OF THE OPERATION AND SO YOU
KNOW ON SUNDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH-
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH THE GOVERNOR DID- ASK US
TO REDUCE CAPACITY IN.
CONSTITUTE PERCENT- AND THEN BY
THE DAY WE WERE TOLD TO CLOSE
WITH THE- EXCEPTION OF THAT YOU
KNOW TAKE OUT AND DELIVERY- AND
THEN BY THAT THURSDAY MARCH
NINETEENTH YOU KNOW EVERYONE
WAS SHELTER IN PLACE. SO THAT
JUST. RESPONDED IN AN
AGGRESSIVE MANNER- AND AS WE
TALK ABOUT THIS WESTERN REGION
STATE PACKED- IT'S IMPORTANT-
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT THE STATE
ACTED QUICKLY AND DECISIVELY NO
DOUBT- THAT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
áP DIFFICULT IT'S BEEN FOR THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY IN THE
RESTAURANT EMPLOYEE BUT YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE QUESTION THAT
WAS RAISED. YOU KNOW HOW THEIR
SECTOR BENEFITS BY THE PHASES
OF RE OPENING. AND IN THE VALUE
OF THE WESTERN PACKED YEAH AND
I THINK ONE THING THAT'S CLEAR
IS ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF THE
PACT WAS YOU KNOW TO PUT
RESIDENTS HEALTH FIRST AND BASE
IT ON HOW COME HELP OUT COMES
IN SCIENCE OVER POLITICS. AND
SO OUR CASE NO QUESTION THESE
CLOSURES HEART WRENCHING- THEY
WERE A DOZEN TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE STATE'S
RESIDENTS. IT'LL BE A THAT
GOVERNOR'S ALLOWED THE FAITH ME
OPEN OF CERTAIN. OF THE ECONOMY.
BASED ON COUNTY THE TESTING
THAT THEY MET CERTAIN PUBLIC
HEALTH BENCHMARKS AND THAT WAS
TRUE FOR THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITIES WELL. SO THE HELP
THAT BENCHMARKS WERE PUT IN
PLACE AND WHERE THE DRIVER FOR
HOW COUNTIES WOULD- SUBMIT
THEIR REQUEST TO RE OPEN I
THINK UNDERSCORES THAT THIS
PORTION OF THE WESTERN- ACT-
DID PLAYING PLAYED OUT
INTENDED- SAFE WHAT WE DO.
WHICH NUMBER ONE ISSUE THE
RESTAURANT. AND OBVIOUSLY
CORONA VIRUSES NOT A FOOD BORNE
ILLNESS BUT OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH- THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT WE LIVE IN ITS
RESTAURANTS- IN TERMS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS. REALLY
PUT ON GOOD FOOTING- TO THE
BEST THAT THE- TO THE BEST.
THAT YOU CAN TAKE PUTTING IN
THE TEXT BECAUSE I HAD A- BEEN
IN THIS. UNDRESSED WHAT WE'RE
IN HANDS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT EVERY DAY IN THE
NONPROFIT NINETEEN PERIOD AND
WE WILL BE AFTER COVERT
NINETEEN INTO MY POINT HERE.
THE GOT THE COUNTY. LOCAL HELP.
YOU'VE GOT. THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
HEALTH DEPARTMENT PAT LONG
BEACH IS AN AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH ALL OF THEM.
INFRASTRUCTURE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH GOT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH THE CONFERENCE OF LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AT THE STATE LEVEL OF
SAFETY COALITION OF THESE
GROUPS ARE A GREAT WAY TO SORT
OF- HARNESS THE ENERGY OF ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
PROVIDE SOME YOU KNOW
CONSISTENT IN SAYING MAP FOR
TRUCKS TO READ. IT TO THAT TAX
STRUCTURE THAT FORM. GOVERNOR
AND THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH- IN ISSUING THE GUIDANCE
RESTAURANT AND WE'RE WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT. SO AS
COUNTIES CONTINUE TO MEET THIS
CRITERIA- OF RE OPENING AND
JUST IN THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS
THERE'S BEEN A FLURRY OF
COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED- FOR. OWNING A
RESTAURANT THE GOVERNOR ALWAYS
SAID APPROPRIATELY THAT THE RE
OPENING OF RESTAURANTS WOULD BE
DONE ON A DIMMER AND NOT A
SWITCH AND THAT'S EXACTLY HOW
IT'S PLAYING OUT. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE EXPECT GOING FORWARD-
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT YOU
KNOW OUR ABSOLUTELY THE BEST
EQUIPPED. TO LOOK REGIONAL RISK
AND DO REGIONAL ANALYSIS AND
DETERMINE- THE CONDITIONS IN
WHICH RESTAURANTS CAN RE OPEN
DINING ROOMS IN PARTICULAR-
FROM REGION TO REGION BECAUSE-
WITHOUT. THAT THE DATA SHOWS
THAT YOU HAVE. DIFFERENT CUTS.
THE VIRUS DIFFERENT PARTS OF.
AND THAT WHAT WE SEEN A LOT OF
THE RURAL COUNTIES RE OPEN REST
STARTING LAST. AND WE JUST THE
DAY THE LAST FEW. WE NUMEROUS
REAL POPULATED COUNTIES START
TO. THE BACK OF THE PACK BUT
WORKED AS AN IT'S STILL.
DIFFICULT THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY TO ADJUST TO THESE
THINGS OF COURSE ARE WORKFORCE
WHICH I'LL GET INTO IN A
MOMENT- INCREDIBLY IMPACTED.
YEAH ANOTHER THING THAT WAS
ASKED IS AT THE REGIONAL
AGREEMENT PROVIDED STABILITY-
FOR OUR SECTOR AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THE REGIONAL. FOR OUR
STREETS IT SELECT RELEVANT FOR
US ENTER. MEETING STABILITY OF
WE'RE NOT A PRODUCT
MANUFACTURER OR RETAILER-
OPERATIONAL CONSISTENCY STATE
TO STATE. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S MY PRIOR
WORLD I'M AT BUT THAT. AND
PLAYED INTO THE AT THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY. EVEN IF
YOU'RE THE STATE RESTAURANT
OPERATOR WHERE YOU MIGHT THINK
THIS REGIONAL AGREEMENT WOULD
HELP WITH CONSISTENCY OF
OPERATE IT REALLY DOESN'T. AS
STATE ACTOR RE OPENING AS WE
SPEAK MAYBE ON A SIMILAR
GENERAL FRAMEWORK WHICH THEY
ARE. BUT AS THE DETAILS OF EACH
OF THOSE LOCALITIES IN THOSE
STATES WHERE PART WITH. OUR
DIFFERENT. THIS IS. THE ISN'T
REALLY WELL TO THE REST OF THE
SOIL I LEAVE THAT QUESTION.
WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT WHAT
CHALLENGES ARE WORKFORCE IS
EXPERIENCING- AGAIN YOU KNOW
MARCH FIFTEENTH YOU HAVE- A
DINING ROOM CAPACITY CUT TO
FIFTY PERCENT. THE THING I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHICH YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU CUT SPENDING ROOM
CAPACITY 250% YOU'RE ALSO
CUTTING- THE NUMBER OF STAFF
AND TEAM MEMBERS THAT IT TAKES.
TO RUN A RESTAURANT SO THE RAP.
CLAMPING DOWN TO PRESS DRAWN
OPERATIONS ABSOLUTELY LED TO
TREMENDOUS JOB LOSS. AND SO
JUST IN THE FIRST THREE WEEKS
OF THE SHUT DOWN WE ESTIMATE
THAT MORE THAN A MILLION
RESTAURANT EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
OUT OF THE MILLION A HALF. WOOD
LAID OUT FOR FURLOUGHED. SO
THAT 70% OF THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY WORK FORCE- LAID OUT
FOR LOW JUST IN THE FIRST THREE
WEEKS. FORTY NINE AND A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT. I AM
SAYING THAT THEY WERE CLOSED SO
AGAIN THAT'S JUST THE THREE
WEEKS. OF THE NUMBERS
PRESUMABLY IT WOULD HAVE ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE WILL HAVE THE
SURVEY DATA BACK IN A WEEK OR
SO. BUT THE BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE RESTAURANT THE
CALIFORNIA NINETY. FOR
STATEWIDE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE OWNED IT UP BY IN THE-
WRITERS. WE HAVE 60% CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS ARE OWNED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR. 64% OF RESTAURANT
WAIT STAFF ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
70% OF RESTAURANT MANAGEMENT
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AND 80% OF
CALIFORNIA CHESTER PEOPLE OF
COLOR. SO THIS REFLECT THE OUR
GREAT DIVERSITY OF THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT ALSO. TO OF
THE GRAPHICS AND DYNAMICS OF.
THE JOB LAW YOU KNOW HAS HAS
RESULTED IN SO EACH DAY THAT
PASSES. READ AN INCORRECT .COM
YEAH. YOU CAN GREAT ANSWER TO
THE RESTAURANT BAR THEIR EMPLOY
IN THERE CAN BE. SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT THE ORGANIZATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IN THE PROCESS OF RE OPENING.
YOU KNOW I THIRTY GOAL AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING- IN ALL OF THE
REGION. THE OPENING AN ATHLETE
EARLY RE OPEN AN INSTITUTE YOU
KNOW PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
DINING ROOMS BATTLE INHERENTLY-
BECAUSE OF REDUCE OCCUPANCY IN
RESTAURANTS AND GUEST COUNT AND
AT THAT MAP IN THAT TRANSLATES
AND PULLING YOUR TEAM MEMBERS
AND STAFF AND OF COURSE WHEN WE
DO ALL OF US WE'RE GENERATING
LEFT TAX AND SALES TAX REVENUE
PER LOCAL. BUT NINETY PUBLIC
THREAT THE STATE ABSOLUTE TOOK
A GREAT FAN YOU KNOW NECESSARY
STEPS TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE STATE'S
RESIDENTS THAT THE KEY
COMPONENT. OF THE PACT-
UNFORTUNATELY. BETA OF THESE
PROTECT PUBLIC UP TO SUSPEND
AND YOUR DESTINATION OF THE
STATE'S RESTAURANT COMMUNITY.
AND NOW WITH AT THE- END NOW
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS BILL HOLD
AS WE'RE SEEING. WE BELIEVE THE
STATE AT THE MORE ALLOW. TAKING
THAT. THEY'VE BEEN CAUSED BY
SEVENTIES MEASURE THE FEDERAL
LACK TAKEN WITH THE BUT PLAN
AND OF OTHER PACK THIS CENTER
IN TERMS OF THE CONCEPT OF THE
IDEAS- ELECTRICAL MEASURES
TAKEN BY THE STATE. IT 2230%
LOSS OF ALL CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT PERMANENTLY. BUT
THERE'S MUCH TO BE DONE AND I
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINK
LEGISLATURE'S CURRENTLY FOCUSED
ON INTENDED TO PROVIDE RELIEF-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH PLEDGES JOHN NUMBER OF
THOSE ISSUES. THANK MISTER
HAYES SPENT OF SHOES ADD THAT
AS A RELATES TO ON AND
INSURANCE RATES. AND THE FACT
THAT WE HAD ABSOLUTELY NO
CONTROL CHOICE OR DESIRE TO
HAVE THE NUMBER OF LAYOFFS THAT
WE'VE HAD WE DO NOT THINK THE
EMPLOYER UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
RATINGS- SHOULD BE INCREASED
AND SHOULD BE A PANEL OF
PENALTY OF FOR EMPLOYERS AND
THERE'S A WAY TO FREE. I KNOW
THAT A NUMBER YOU MISSED ARE
LOOKING AT ISSUE WHEN WE PRE
THAT THERE'S ISSUES RELATED TO
BUSINESS INTERRUPTION
INSURANCE- THERE'S COUNTLESS
REGULATIONS- BEING- PROPAGATED
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WHICH WE ARE
PRODUCTIVE PART. IN THE
DISCUSSION AND WE KNOW IN THE
END THOSE WILL IN FACT BE
REGULATIONS BUT FOR RIGHT NOW
IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS. THIS
WERE. THINGS GET PUT ON POTS
FOR A TEMPORARY TIME PERIOD.
WE'RE LOOKING LOT OF DIFFERENT
POLICY PROPOSAL THAT NO CAN
HELP OF HIBERNATE THROUGH THE
REST OF THIS BUT ALSO TO RE
EMERGE AS THE- STATE. THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYERS. THE
FINAL ONE OF THE FINAL
QUESTIONS WAS CHALLENGES THAT
OUR MEMBERSHIP HAS HAD AN
ACQUIRING PP- AND THAT'S A
FANTASTIC QUESTION NO I THINK
WHAT WHAT I'D SAY AT THE OUTSET
IS KEEP IN MIND WE LARGELY BEEN
CLOSED VERY FEW WORK IN
RESTAURANTS- IT IF YOU WITH NO
REVENUE COMING IN. LIMITED TO
TAKE OUT OPTION AND THAT THAT
NOT A LOT OF REVENUE YOU'RE NOT
BREAKING THE WITH THAT BUT IT
DOES GIVE YOU SOMETHING TO HELP
IMPROVE. SO THE SHORT POINT IS.
WE ARE EMPLOYING VERY PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
GOVERNMENT MANDATE TO SHUT
DOWN. AS WE COME OUT FROM THAT
WILL BE RE STAFFING AND
BRINGING ALL THOSE GREAT PEOPLE
BACK ON BOARD AND THAT. THE
TRUE DEMAND FOR PP. IT FELT BY
OUR CAN BE. HELP OUR SO FAR YOU
KNOW COVER. I HAVE BEEN AND THE
NORMAN STREET FOR A TEMA. AND
EVEN FOR GAS AND SOME
TERRITORY- INITIALLY THERE WAS
A SCRAMBLE TO ACQUIRE ALL THAT
NEED SUPPLY OF BASS COVER BUT-
HE HAD. ABILITY THAT I THINK
THE MOTHER STONE AND THAT THAT
IS THAT WE CAN USE NON MEDICAL
GREAT PACE COVER- AND SO
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY THERE JUST IN
TERMS. APPLY AND THAT AND EIGHT
YOU KNOW I JUST THINK THE OTHER
ISSUES AS IT RELATES TO HAND
SANITIZERS AND OTHER FORMS OF
PP- YEAH INITIALLY- THERE WAS
SHORTAGE- THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
GET THE MOST OF THE THINGS WE-
BRING IN. AND ACQUIRING ABOUT
EARLY. MANY OF THEM HAVE BECOME
TRONG RECOMMENDATIONS IF NOT
MANDATES BUT THE LOCAL. HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS WE SLOWLY RE
OPENED- AND SO YOU KNOW THE
FINAL THING OUT THEY IN THIS
POINT. IT'S AN ARTICLE SYSTEM
OF FROM BUYERS FOR THEIR FOOD
PREPARERS ARE DRINK FOOD AND
BEVERAGE THERE'S- ALSO HAVE A
NUMBER OF SUPPLIERS. THAT DO
PROVIDE A THIS. BUT SO BEEN
FORTY. I'M NOT SURE NEW HE HAD
PEOPLE ARE SUPPLYING HAVE THAT
PROVIDE THOSE ITEMS AND THEY
HAVE BEEN THEY BEEN FANTASTIC-
BUT THE CITIES HAVE HELPED
SUPPLY US AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HELP SUPPLY US. UNIQUE DO MAKE
THINGS. HIS MANY FOR BASE AND
OTHERS AND I THINK THEY'LL BE A
LOT OF NEW AND CREATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS TO COME OUT OF
THIS WHEN IT COMES TO PP
BECAUSE IN OUR WORLD. WE KNOW
THAT RESTAURANT ADDING ROOMS
GOING TO BE LET THAN FULL
CAPACITY THE NEAR FUTURE. NO
BASED ON HELP IF YOU. IN PLACE
BY THE AND THE LOW. COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT. PP
WHEN IT COMES TO FACE COVERINGS
HAND SANITIZERS EVEN PARTITIONS
AND BARRIERS BETWEEN RESTAURANT
BUT- TO ACCOMMODATE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE THE NORM
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN PLACE
FOR A WHILE. AND SO AS WE RE
OPEN. IF YOU'RE GOING
GANGBUSTERS WITH RE OPENING
AGAIN JUST IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
SO THE DEMAND FOR THESE
PRODUCTS ISSUED UP
TREMENDOUSLY- A LOT OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
ACQUIRE- THESE ITEMS FOR THEIR
COUNTY RE OPENED SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT CAUGHT. BUT IT.
AGAIN THE FACT IN TACTIC CAN
HELP PROVIDE DISTANCE THOSE ARE
THE PRIOR ECOSYSTEM- SO WITH
REGARD TO THE QUESTION PLAYED
OUT- TO OUR CERTIFICATION ON
THE VALUE OF THE WESTERN STATES
PACKED. THOSE THAT THE COMMENTS
THAT I WOULD PROVIDE AT THIS
POINT. AND CERTAINLY HAVE
PLENTY MORE TO SAY ON THE TOPIC
BUT IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
THINK OF WRAP IT UP THERE AND-
CERTAINLY WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. DURING MY
MASTERS IN AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE PANELISTS YOU. IN REAL
DETAIL IT. IS ABOUT. JUST A-
ASPECTS OF HOW THE PACKED
IMPACTS YOU BUT ALSO ABOUT
COLLABORATION- AND PARTNERSHIPS
THAT YOU HAVE. BEEN WORKING ON
DURING THIS TIME AND THAT
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN HELPFUL FOR
ALL OF US OF WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO GET THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC. I DO TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY. THE COMMITTEE TO
ASK FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS TO THE
PANELISTS. AND WE WILL WE ARE
WORKING WITH A PHONE MODERATOR
AND THAT THOSE ARE MAGIC WORDS
I GUESS FOR ATTENTION WHEN WE
SAY THOSE WORDS. AND SHE IS
THEN SPAHN OF TO- TO OUR
REQUESTS AND SO THE
INSTRUCTIONS ARE TO USE THOSE
MAGIC WORDS PHONE MODERATOR AND
THEN TO USE THE FULL NAME AND
THE ORGANIZATION THAT THE
PERSON REPRESENTS. THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE QUESTION
TO. US THAT SHE KNOWS WHO TO
ME. ON THE LINE- TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION IT MAY
BE SOMEWHAT CUMBERSOME AS WELL
AS THEIR- AT. ARE TO BE SOME
QUESTIONS BUT ASKED MANY PEOPLE
SO WILL WILL CYCLE THROUGH AND
IT WILL ALL HAVE THE SHINS TO
MAKE EVERYONE FEEL TO GET. IF
YOU HAVE. SINCE YEAH AND SOME
THANK GOODNESS MY FIRST. A
MAJOR FROM THE FARM BUREAU SO I
HAD A QUESTION- WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD MOST ECONOMIES
A CONDOM IS THAT I'VE SPOKEN TO
ARE PREDICTING A REDUCE
CONSUMER DEBT AND FOR
RESTAURANTS IN THE TERM BOOK
DUE TO DECREASED JUST COME AS
WELL AS DECREASE DEMAND FOR IN
A BECAUSE PEOPLE DEVELOP TO
FEED HER FACE TO FACE THANK OUT
MOUNTAIN FROM THE- RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. HAS ABOUT MANY
RESTAURANTS HOW THEY'RE COPING
WITH. WHAT WE SPEAKING YOUR HOW
MUCH OF THE- FARM DEMAND. GOES
TO RESTAURANTS.WHAT SHOULD WE
KNOW OUR HOW SHOULD WE ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ADDITIVE ADEQUATE
FOOD SUPPLY FOR CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS. AND BROADER WITH
IN OUR WESTERN STATES PACKED SO
WE KNOWS A LARGE PORTION OF
FOOD GOES TO RESTAURANTS WE
NEVER TO CONTINUE REDUCE AND
THEIR HOPEFULLY WILL PICK UP
YOU KNOW. AS WE GO FORWARD. BUT
HOW DO WE THAT HOLDER THIS SO
WE SHARE WITH BENEFIT OUT OF.
SUPPLY FOR CALVET IN OUR
WESTERN PART THE ONE. FOR SURE
THAT THAT COULD FOODS UP RIGHT
NOW BOTTOM IS ON THE- AN ISSUE
WITH DISTRIBUTION IN TERMS HOW
WE GET THE PRODUCT FROM. EITHER
OUR FARMS TO ARREST AND TORE A
TO THE FOOD SERVICE OUR TO OUR
GROCERY SHELVES THE FOOD SUPPLY
IS ADEQUATE RIGHT NOW. SO THE
FOOD WE EAT THE FOOD SUPPLY
CHAIN TRONG- BUT WE NEED TO PUT
A LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY AND PUT
ONE OF THE ASPECTS WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF SOME SORT WE SAW. IS
THAT IN TERMS OF FOOD PROCESS
IT FOR YOU A RESTAURANT MAY BE
A DIFFERENT CUT OF MEAT THAN
WHAT GENERALLY. TO A INTO CA A
DIFFERENT. BUT JEFF SORT THAT
ARE ABLE TO HANDLE A LARGER CUT
OF MEAT AND CUT IT INTO THE
PORTIONS THAT THEY WANT WHERE
IS THIS NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
SERVINGS THAT SOMETIMES YOU SEE
ON THE CONCERT TRAIL FOR
EXAMPLE ALSO SAY FOR BETTER IF
OF AN INCH IN BUTTER BEING
HARDEST 60% ENDING UP IN THE
FOOD SERVICE AND RESTAURANT.
ISN'T THAT. THAT'S THOSE AT
THOSE. FOOD SERVICE THE-
DOESN'T PROCESS IN THE LITTLE
CUBES ONE POUND PACKAGES THAT
THAT WE BY THE GROCERY STORE. A
PACKAGE IN FIFTY FIVE GALLON
BARRELS OF BUTTER AND THEN THAT
IS BROKEN DOWN. AND OF COURSE
YOU KNOW SOME YOUR LARGE
BAKERIES USE A LOT OF A LOT
BETTER- SO IT'S A MATTER OF.
HOW DO WE RETOOL DOWN IN THAT.
COME OVERNIGHT- RETOOLING A
PROCESSING PLANT ANYWHERE FROM
YEAR TO. MORE LIKELY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
CONVERT FROM A DO A- PERSON
FOOD SERVICED MORE INTO.
PACKAGING BUT I THINK HE
THOUGHT IN THIS IS MORE ON THE-
LEVEL SOME OF THESE ARE ALSO.
LAWS IN MEMBER. I WILL. STATUS
DE. FOR A- PACK. FOR A. RETAIL
FOOD SERVICE BE. IN A BOX. YEAH
IT'S A THIRTY DOZEN AT A TIME
BOXES. THAT LABEL THAN IT IS ON
THE CAN SIDE SO WHAT IT TOOK
AND ASSIST THE CREDIT OF USD-
ACTED FAST AND- ACCURATE. MY
THEIR LABELING REQUIREMENTS
MEANING. A TO GET EGGS ON THE
MARKET- THE X. COULD BE A
LITTLE BIT OLDER THAN YOU
USUALLY ALLOWED FOR THE
CONSUMER MARKET A FORTUNATE
THAT WAS AROUND EASTER IF YOU
REMEMBER SO THERE WAS A LARGE
SUPPLY OF EGGS THAT WERE ALSO
AVAILABLE. BUT IT WILL TAKE
SOME RETOOLING BOTH ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE IN TERMS OF SOME
LABELING LAWS IF WE REALLY WANT
TO- STREAMLINED HOW WE GET MORE
FOOD TO THE CONSUMER SHELF BUT
AT THIS TIME REALLY. THERE IS
THERE A SHORTAGE OF FOOD AND OF
THAT STORE SHELVES MAY BE. OUR
FIELDS ARE BARNES ARE NOT. SO
J. CENTER THAT QUESTION. IT
WILL. IF YOU WOULD KEEP A
ABREAST OF WHAT WE COULD DO AND
CALIFORNIA RIGHT SOME OF THAT
SOME OF THAT FAT AND I KNOW.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THEM. BUT WHAT CAN WE DO HERE
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THE
PICTURES OF MY- DOWN THE DRAIN
AND PICTURES EVER SEEN ABOUT
FARM WASTING FOOD WASTE WHEN WE
KNOW WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE.
THAT ARE GOING HUNGRY I HAVE SO
MANY. TO DO A KNOWLEDGE HERE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN FOR
LOW. AND THEY DON'T HAVE FOOD
AND SO IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM.
RIGHT THAT WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW
YOU SEE THE IMAGES AND YET YOU
HAVE THESE PEOPLE HUNGRY SO I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE A CHALLENGE. AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS SESSION. PLEASE
THAT IS. WHAT WE CAN DO STERN
HELPFUL FAURIA. MAYBE THAT. OF
THE ONE STATE DO THAT THAT THE
PACKAGE. HOW TO BE. HONEST SOME
OF YOU KNOW. CONCERT SPACE. IT
JUST ADDRESS THANKS PHONE.
BUZZED BUT THERE IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S KIND OF INTERESTING IS
ROLLING EVEN TO BE COUNTY. AND
I KNOW IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THAT WAS THE GOVERNOR INSTANT
IMPLEMENTING YOU CUT THROUGH
THE ON- THE RESTAURANT TO
SENIORS PROGRAM. AND A LOT OF
OUR SMALLER LOCALLY OWNED
RESTAURANTS ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT TO SMALL FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. AND IN OUR HIGHER
END. UP ATTACKS BECAUSE OF
PURCHASING DIRECTLY SO. PROGRAM
IS THAT. YOU ALSO. I'VE WORKED
WITH. MANY FARM BUREAU STATE
PRESS IN TERMS OF THE NEED FOR
PRODUCE AND SOME OF THESE
WESTERN STATES WORKS IN OUR
BACKYARD. AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
JUST COMING IN THE SEASON HOW
CAN WE EFFICIENTLY. GET THEM
WHEN YOU KNOW ONE FOOD BANK A
CAN'T HANDLE YOU KNOW ONE SEMI
TRUCK WILL PRODUCE. GET IT
SOMEWHERE. YOU KNOW. AFFORDABLE
THANK YOU SIGN AT THE NOW USE
YOUR PROTOCOL I'M NOT SURE WHAT
WAS THE MAGIC WORD. PHONE
MODERATOR. COULD YOU PLEASE PUT
ON THE LINE SARAH FOX FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
AIRLINES OPEN. IT WORKS THE
SERRA YOU MENTION THAT- A
CERTAIN CHUNK OF JOBS ARE NOT
COMING BACK IN AND WHEN YOU
MADE YOUR STATEMENT AND ONE OF
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN VERY
PREOCCUPIED WITH IS WHAT IS
THAT LOOK LIKE SECTOR BY SECTOR
AND WHAT RETRAINING PROGRAMS DO
YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT A CERTAIN SECTORAL JOBS.
MATT MATCH TO THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. I WOULD LVE TO
SEE AT AN ANALYSIS OF WHERE
JOBS AREN'T COMING BACK I JEAN.
ARTICLES AND SOME ECONOMISTS
TALKING ABOUT THIS I THINK IT
WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE SOME OF
OUR- EXCELLENT RESEARCH-
UNIVERSITIES LOOK. THAT OR OUR
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR ALSO HAS A
PROPOSED FOR BURKE AND
PARCHMENT WHICH IS GOING TO.
PUT TOGETHER A LOT OF OUR WORK
FORCE TRAINING PROGRAM SO THAT
MIGHT BE A GOOD PLACE TO DO A
SCAN OF THE ECONOMY. AND SAY
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE GROWTH
HERE SO WE NEED TO DEVELOP
APPROPRIATE TRAINING PROGRAMS I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT. A TRAINING PROGRAM AND
IF THAT PERSON GETTING A JOB. I
DON'T CAN CHAIR TRAINING GRAHAM
OR SIX STORM. ACTUALLY PLACE.
JOB WHERE. THEIR EIGHT. PAGE
THAT BEING PLACE SOMEWHAT THE-
SUPPLEMENT BACK WITH PUBLIC
BENEFIT LIKE MEDICAID FOR OTHER
PER. I THEN OF COURSE BLOCKING
A OUR AND STATE PRO IN MY YOU
LEARN WE IS REALLY THE BEST WAY
I CAN. PER WORKER TO BE ABLE TO
TRY LOW NEWS BUT ALSO MAKE
MONEY SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
SUPPORT A FAMILY AND INVESTMENT
WILL COMMUNITIES BUT I DO THINK
GETTING THAT DATA AND
DEVELOPING TRAINING PROGRAMS
BASED ON WHERE JOB GROWTH GOING
TO BE IN THE FUTURE IT GOING TO
BE IN. REPORT. THANK YOU- AND
MY LAST QUESTION IS- PHჭ
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE PUT
ON THE LINE. LANCE HASTINGS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING ASSOCIATION.
PLANTS ARE LINED UP IN. WELL
THANK YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT
THERE WERE VERY WELL RUN
MODERATOR AND HEARING THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I HAVE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK THIS
PANDEMIC HAS DEMONSTRATED IS
THE PROBLEM WITH VERY LONG
SUPPLY CHAINS ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO PP. WHAT IS IT THAT
WE CAN WORK WITHIN THE WESTERN
STATES OR WITHIN CALIFORNIA-
WITH YOU. TO INCREASE THE
AGILITY FOR OUR MANUFACTURING
TO PIVOT TO THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. IF WE HAVE A SECOND
SURGE OR GOD FORBID A FUTURE
PANDEMIC HOW IS IT THAT WHAT IS
IT THAT WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT FOR BEING MORE AGILE AND
MANUFACTURING TO HAVE. THE A TO
ON SHORE PP AND SOME OF THAT
MANUFACTURING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE QUESTION I MEAN IT IS
ACTUALLY A TWO DIMENSIONAL
ISSUE. IN TRYING TO MANAGE
SUPPLY CHAINS AND MY COMMENTS
EARLIER I MENTIONED LOCAL
REGIONAL NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
ECONOMY SIT BACK THAT THAT IS
WHAT WE HAVE. AND I DID WANT TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT. IT IS PART OF
THIS ANSWER TO THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH. THAT
BEING OPERATING AT PASSED THE-
DURING THAT SUPPLY CHAIN- OF
PRODUCTS SAID PLIES. THE
MATERIAL IS CONSISTENT COMING
THROUGH THERE DO. HAVE MARK
SAID PROBABLY AN AND HERALD
HEROES DOWN THERE BE ABLE TO
KEEP THOSE PROFITS WITH LONG SO
TO GIVE A- PROPER SHOT OUT TO
THE- PORTABLE ANGELES. WE DO
HAVE THAT GLOBAL SO A THEIR IS
THAT AFTER HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL WOULD MAKE. LOOK SOME OF
THE CALLS WE GOT AFTER.
FINISHING SHOCK SAID IN WERE
MANUFACTURE VERTICALLY OF LOS
ANGELES AREA ASKING. HOW COULD
THEY REPURPOSE THEIR OPERATIONS
AND START MAKING PP AND OTHER
NECESSARY ITEMS BECAUSE THEY'RE
WILLING TO DO SO. THE CHALLENGE
WITH THAT IS THEY MAY HAVE THE
EMPLOYEES THAT WE HAVE THE TWO
MILLION AND DESIRE. THE FINANCE
SUPPORT. AND NINETY FIVE MASS
YOU LOOK BAD AVE. HELPS YEAH
THE MEDICAL GRADE WAS THE
IMMEDIATE. AT TO GET THE PRICE
OF BUT- YEAH IT'S JUST. THAT
NEW THAT MENTIONED THAT WE
DON'T NEED BETTER GRADE IN.
INDUSTRIAL SETTING. CNC MEMBERS
ARE POSITIONED TO HELP WITH
THAT- SO CALIFORNIANS MAKING
THANKS FOR CALIFORNIANS. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THAT. BOTH IN THE TWO YEAR
TERM BUT OVER THE NEXT MONTH.
IN CASE IN MOST MEDICAL EXPERTS.
SAY WE CAN THEY NOT. WELL I
STARTED BY. PUNCHED IN THE
MOUTH BUT NOW WE BEEN ABLE TO
OF THE DAY. IN THAT SECOND
PUNCH LATER THE YEAR TO OUR
MEMBERS ARE WORKING. AT TIRE.
IMPACT AB IT'S ON THE PANEL
FROM THE INDUSTRY'S ARE.
PARTNERING TOGETHER TO INSURE
THAT WE HAVEN'T SO THEN. SLASH
PP. WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND YEAH GO
BE ON THIS MATTER. SO WE'RE
HOPING TO. BE ABLE TO
INTRODUCE. AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS SEEN THEM. WE CAN ASSURE THE
PUBLIC THAT WE'RE TAKING GREAT
STEPS TO. INSURE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT ALSO. BECAUSE GOING UNDER A
MUCH DIFFERENT PAIR NINE MOVING
TOLD. THANK YOU. FAMOUS FOR HER
MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING BECAUSE IT'S- ASIDE
FROM IT BEING A FASCINATING
TOPIC TO TALK ABOUT IT SOME OF
THE TIDBITS THAT YOU PICK UP
ABOUT WHETHER THE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE BILLION IN
RETAIL OR 80% OF. BEING AND NON
FEMALE PARTY THESE THESE YEAH
IT'S A IT'S GREAT TO KIND OF
BRUSH UP ON SOME OF THE NUMBERS
AND THE VAST LIST OF- THE ISSUE
THE DEAL AND HOW WE TRY TO.
DATE A THE VERY USED TO THE
MOVING PARTS WITH THEM. THE
MISS. KAMLAGER HAD LEAVE TO
FACILITATE A CALL A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DELEGATION CALL THAT I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE ON AS WELL BUT
SO SHE- PESTANA QUESTION- TO MR
JOHANNSEN THAT I WANTED TO
DIRECT MONTH ON HER BEHALF- WE
HAVE HEARD ABOUT FARMERS
DESTROYING PRODUCT BECAUSE OF
THE DIMINISHED HOW. DO WE
REDESIGN A SUPPLY AND GOODS
CHAIN THAT WILL PREVENT THIS
FROM HAPPENING. AND THEN THE
WILL BE ASKING A QUESTION A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS OF MY OWN
YEAH THERE THERE IS- NOTHING
MORE DISHEARTENING HAS- I WAS
DOING INTERVIEWS ON KABC SEVEN
LIVE. YOU KNOW DOWN A LOS
ANGELES AND PRECEDING ME WAS A
STORY OF LONG LINES AT A COSCO.
AND THIS WAS ABOUT TWO WEEKS
FOR THE SEARCH TERM SORTERS AND
THE QUESTIONS COMING UP. A THAT
WERE TO ME YOU IN TERMS OF IS
SHORTAGE WHAT YOU KNOW THOSE
CONCERNS AT THE SAME TIME
GETTING REPORTS FROM MY FELLOW
FARMERS AND STATE FARM YOUR
PRESIDENT'S. ABOUT THE MILK
DUMPING HAPPY IN WISCONSIN
HAPPENING- YOU KNOW I HADN'T.
HEARD OF ANY CALIFORNIA AT TH
TIME IS STILL HAVEN'T DIRECTLY
TO ANYONE. I'M SO IT'S
CONCERNING BUT IT GOES TO THAT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FOOD CHAIN
AND THAT WILL BE A VERY- THAT
WILL BE A VERY WELL THIS STE A
TOPIC IN TERMS F HOW. TO
CHANGE OR FOR. HOW WOULD BY HOW
CAN WE PROVIDE MORE- PROCESSORS
FOR FARMERS TO TURN TO WHO
CATER TO. YOU KNOW- NOT JUST
ONE SEGMENT OF THE FOOD CHAIN
AND THAT'S A MATTER HAVING MORE
COMPETITION IN THE MARKETPLACE.
AND WE CAN BECOME VERY
SPECIALIZED IN VERY. VERY GOOD
AT WHAT WE DO AND THE DIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SUCH THAT WE
OFTEN FORGET HOW COMPLEX. THE
COMPLEXITY THAT'S NECESSARY FOR
THAT DIVERSITY- SO- THERE'S NO
QUICK EASY ANSWER RIGHT NOW. IN
TERMS OF STOPPING THAT TO
HAPPEN- BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT
THAT YOU KNOW SIMPLY CUT FOOD
MILK. PLANT COULD TAKE MORE
MELTED IN THE CAPACITY
PASTEURIZATION ASSIST. TO GET
THE CONSUMER HAND. OR TO A YOU
PUT A IN FOR THE. HE SAID. IT'S
A QUITE. KOCHHAR YOU KNOW. FOOD
PROCESS WILL BE WILL BE
DISCUSSING FOR A LONG TIME.
THANK YOU. LIKE I GOT TWO
QUESTIONS. AND THIS IS I'D LIKE
ALL OF THE- SPEAKERS AND
PANELISTS TODAY TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT SO I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE ALL LISTS INTO THE
AN OR IF WE NEED TO INDIVIDUAL.
THANK YOU. FOR MODERATE IF YOU
MAKE EVERY HEARS THIS QUESTION
AND EVERYONE IN ORDER IS ABLE
TO OR WHOEVER CHOOSES TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANSWERING.
ANSWERS IT. SO ONE IS. IN
GENERAL AND. A AND YOU YOU WERE
ASKED THIS QUESTION SO I
APOLOGIZE IN KIND OF BRING THIS
UP BUT I FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE I'M SURE
WITHIN EVERYONE'S TRADE ARENA-
THERE ARE THESE CONVERSATIONS
OF WHAT THE- SECTOR- AND THE
MARKET SECTOR. BUT THE
PRODUCTION AS WELL AS THE
MARKET IS GONNA LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE HOW IS THIS GONNA
CHANGE HOW'S EVERYTHING GOING
TO CHANGE. WHAT THE NEW NORMAL
IS GONNA BE IN PART OF THE
REASON WHY I ASK IS WE'RE GONNA
OVERCOME. THIS SPECIFIC VIRUS
BUT THIS CAUGHT US FLAT FOOTED
AND THIS DEMONSTRATED TO US THE
FRAGILITY OF THE- SYSTEMS WE
HAVE IN PLACE. AND THE MARGINS
THAT WE OPERATE AT AND SO IT IT
THE IT BASICALLY- UNVEILED A
LOT OF AREAS THAT- A LOT OF
AREAS ESPECIALLY IN HEALTH CARE
THAT THAT THAT. WE'RE OPERATING
AT SUCH THIN MARGINS THAT-
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF CHALLENGES
TOOK TO OVERCOME. SO HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU SEE THE FUTURE. OF
YOUR SPECIFIC INDUSTRY OR
SECTOR BOTH IN THE PRODUCTION
SIDE AS WELL AS ON THE MARKET
SIDE. CHANGING. I KNOW IT'S
VERY BROAD BUT- BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR BECAUSE
TODAY IT'S COVERED NINETEEN
TOMORROW BUT MAY BE SOMETHING
ELSE SOMETHING A LOT MORE EVEN
AGGRESSIVE THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH A CO OF NINETEEN AND JUST
FOR THIS GO ON. CLEAR AND- XIN
WILL AGAIN MISTER JOHNSON
JOHANNSEN AND THEN WE'LL CALL
THE NAMES AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS. IN SUCCESSIVE
ORDER- FOR AN OPPORTUNE FOR
EACH OF THEM TO HELP THE PHONE
MODERATOR- ORGANIZE THAT
TRAFFIC THAT THANK YOU YEP YOU
KNOW I CAN ASK BOTH QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW AND EVERYONE CAN
ANSWER BOTH QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH. THIS
IS OUR IN THANK YOU THE SECOND
POINT WAS AND THIS IS AND TOTAL
AND MATT MISTER SUTTON THE- I
NOT PICK IN UP. ON THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION THE REST
INDUSTRY FOR YET BUT IT'S THE
BEST EXACT THAT CAN. IN
STRAIGHT. PROVIDE THAT
DEMONSTRATES. A VERY CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF ALL SECTORS- THAT
THAT THAT- CAN FALTER. THE
OTHER NIGHT MACINNES MENTIONED
IN RESTAURANTS NAME I WAS IN
SACRAMENTO I WAS CAN WE AFTER I
LEFT THE- CAPITOL BUILDING AT A
SEVEN. OCT WHEN BY SOMETHING TO
EAT. AND WHEN I. FRONT DOOR
OPEN I WALKED PUT IN AN ORDER
AND THE- OF VERY HELPFUL-
INDIVIDUAL AT THE BEHIND THE
DESK BEHIND THE COUNTER BEGAN
STARTING PREPARING THE MEAL.
AND OF HE WAS USING HIS GLOVES
AND EVERYTHING WAS FINE BUT AS
HE WENT DOWN THE ASCENT THE
FOOD ASSEMBLY LINE. APPEARING
THE MEAL FINISHED IT UP AND
LOOKED AROUND TO SEE IF THE-
CASHIER WAS WAS THERE REALIZE
THE CASHIER WAS OUTSIDE DOING
SOMETHING ELSE SO HE
PROCEEDEDAND TAKING MY PAYMENT
RINGING
ME UP AND TAKING MY PAYMENT
EVERYTHING WAS FINE AND NORMAL.
I JUST NOTICED THOUGH THAT WHEN
HE- TOOK MY PAYMENT HE TOOK MY
CREDIT CARD MADE THE PAYMENT.
CHARGE MY CARD GIVE THE CARD
BACK TO ME AND JUST OUT OF
INTEREST I WANTED TO SEE IF. HE
WAS GONNA TAKE OFF HIS GLOVES.
UP I WALK OUT AND I SLOWLY
WALKED TO MY VEHICLE SO THAT I
A TAKE ENOUGH TIME AND IT WAS A
VERY LONG MAYBE A MINUTE- TIE
MY SHOELAE DID DID DIFFERENT
THINGS TWO CHESTS SEE WHAT WAS
GONNA HAPPEN. UP ULTIMATELY FOR
THE MINUTE THAT I OBSERVED HIM
HE DIDN'T- CHANGES GLOVES AND
HE WENT BACK TO CLEANING UP HIS
STATION WORKSTATION AND TECH.
CATER TO THE NEXT PERSON. I
BRING THIS UP BECAUSE- WE CAN
GO THROUGH. THE STEPS OF
ANYTHING. TO BRING A ENTIRE
WORLD ECONOMY TO A SCREECHING
HALT. GET OF CERTAIN THIRDS
AREN'T. WELL ESTABLISHED.
YOU'RE A AT AT AT THE MOST
SIMPLEST LINE AMONG THE
BUSINESS CHAIN THANKS COULD
EASILY BROKEN BREAK UP. YEAH
THE- AND YOUR FIVE JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT I'M SAYING WE CAN
GO THROUGH ALL THE PAINFUL
CHOICES BUSINESSES CAN SHUT
DOWN PEOPLE HAVE TO MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
EVERYTHING CHANGES IN THE ARENA
AND BECOMES DIFFICULT BUT UP
FOR THE VERY PURPOSE OF MAKING
SURE THAT. THE CERTAIN QUALITY
IS GUARANTEED AND A SHIRT AND
PEOPLE SAFETY ARE ASSURED YET.
YOU KNOW ALL IT TAKES IS FOR
THAT GLOVES THOSE GLOVES NOT TO
CHANGE. AND UP FOR THE CAR
CROSS CONTENT THE CONTAMINATION
TO TAKE PLACE BECAUSE WHEN THAT
GENTLEMAN TOOK MY CREDIT CARD
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER I. HAVE
THE VIRUS OR NOT- I BRING THIS
UP BECAUSE THIS CAN HAPPEN IN
ANY INDUSTRY. IT CAN HAPPEN IN
ANY PLACE IT JUST THIS WAS THE
BEST EXAMPLE BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S THAT WE'RE ALL
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW AND WE
SEE IT UP FRONT. AND SO. WHAT
ARE YOU GONNA BE THE STANDARDS
WATER HOW WERE THE INCENTIVES
GOING TO BE PUT INTO PLACE.
WITH INCENTIVES OR STANDARD
SOME SPEAKING OF LOOSENING
STANDARDS IN CERTAIN CASES. YOU
KNOW HOW WE SOME. UP PROCEDURES
STANDARDS INCENTIVES GOING TO
BE PUT INTO PLACE OR WHAT NEEDS
TO BE PUT INTO PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. EVEN AT THE MOST. A
BASIC LEVEL OF RISK EXECUTION.
THINGS ARE DONE IN A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ALL THIS THAT'S
HAPPENING. IS FOR NOT. BECAUSE
OF THE VERY SMALL MISTAKE THAT
HAPPENS AT THE TAIL END OF THE
EXECUTION. SO SORRY FOR THE
VERY LENGTHY- QUESTION AN
ANECDOTE BUT BUT I THOUGHT IT'S
JUST THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO PAY ATTENTION TO SOME OF
THESE DETAILS AS WELL. THANK
YOU. WELL I GUESS I'LL START ON.
YEAH IT'S A COMPLEX QUESTION
THAT LIKE I SAID IN THE
PREVIOUS IN THE PREVIOUS ONE
WE'RE GOING TO BE WRESTLING
WITH FOR A LONG TIME BUT
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
QUICK PIVOT TO FLEXIBILITY. AND
THAT MAY BE ON A FARM LIKE SUCH
AS MINE I MAY BE SELLING TO A
PROCESSOR- WHO JUST CELLS- MY
OLIVE OIL IN MY ALL OF THE
GOING DAHLE BOIL TO RETAILER OR
TO- INTO A FOOD SERVICE THE
FIFTY FIVE GALLON BARRELS. CAN
I. FLEX TO- AS IF THAT CONTRACT
RISE UP CAN I CAN I MOVE TO A
DIRECT CONSUMER SALE CAN I MOVE
BACK INTO THE FARMER'S MARKET
OR EVEN AN ONLINE PRESENCE AND
WE'RE SEEING FARMS
TRADITIONALLY LARGER FARMS
HAVING PLAYED IN THAT ARENA
BEGIN TO INTRODUCE THOSE THOSE
DIRECT TO CONSUMER- PLANS JUST
LIKE WE HAVE TYPICALLY SEEN IN
SOME OF OUR OUR SMALLER FARMS-
WE HAVE TO LOOK AND HAVE TO
HAVE AN HONEST DISCUSSION
ABOUT- THE- HOW WE HAVE LOST
REGION AUDI. IN THE WEST AND
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR IN
TERMS OF- THE PROCESSORS
AVAILABLE WHETHER THAT'S AN ALL
OF PROCESSING PLANT OR A MEAT
PACKING PLANT OR A CUSTOM- MEAT
PACKING PLANT WE HAD STRONG
REGIONALISM WHEN I STARTED TO I
STARTED FARMING I START MY FARM
IN NINETY THREE AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THE SEVEN AND EIGHT OR
FOURTEEN IF ALL OF. OUR SUIT
FOR THE DOLLAR. THERE NOT
MAKING THAT. SITUATION ROSE IN
TERMS OF OUR- IMPORTANT AND
WHAT NOT BUT THERE. WE END UP
ONLY TWO NOW IN THE- WHICH IS
VERY LIMITING IN TERMS OF WHO
CAN SELL TO THEM SO LOT OF US
WERE LOCKED INTO AN OLIVE OIL
MARKET- WE CAN LOOK AT THE MEAT
PACKING PLANTS WE SEE PEOPLE
NOW- AT CONTACTING. A LOT OF
RANCHERS INTERESTED IN BUYING
HALF OF BE FOR YOU KNOW A SHARE
OF A QUARTER A THIRD- BUT THERE
SIMPLY ISN'T THE CAPACITY OF A
LOCAL BUTCHER SHOP. AND THEN WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE STATE
STANDARDS THAT WOULD PREVENT
THE EXPANSION OF THAT AND- AND
A LOT OF THAT IS A FEDERAL
STANDARD BUT CAN THE STATE.
PLAY A BETTER. IN TERMS OF
EASING THE REGULATIONS OF. OF
A- LETTING CONSUMERS GO DIRECT
TO FARMERS. TOM THE FEAR
HOWEVER IS THAT IS THAT BECOMES
A NECESSITY TO BE ABLE TO PLAY
BOTH IN A RETAIL. AND IN A IN A
IN A DIRECT TO CONSUMER SALES.
AND MAYBE MICROPTERIX TO CHANGE
MAYBE I HAVE TO ADD ANOTHER.
CROP THAT. APPEALS THAT COULD
CARRY ME THROUGH THE TOUGH
TIMES THAT MAYBE IS MORE OF
JUST A- A CONSUMER. GROCERY
STORE TYPE PRODUCT- AND IF I
CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THAT IN THE
MARKET DEMANDS IT FIRST- WE
HAVE CONSULTED. AND I. THINK
THAT WE GOT. OUR CULTURES. TO
PREVENT THAT THE CONSOLIDATION
FORTY HAPPEN A MONSTER. MORE
ALSO IS. HAVE SIX HAPPEN WITH
HER FARMS. AS A WE GET.AS
REGULATIONS AND AS- POSSIBLE AS
FOR US WE IN. A IN A RECENT
STUDY. ON A LETTUCE FIELD IN
SALINAS OVER THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS- THE JUST THE REGULATORY
COSTS OF PRODUCING THAT
LETTUCE. HAS RISEN OVER 7100%
IN THE LAST TWELVE YEARS.
THAT'S A HUGE BURDEN ON A
FARMER. AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT
THE DIRECT. PROGRAMS BY USDA WE
TALK ABOUT. THE TAX CREDITS THE
STUFF WE GET WORKING WITH FOOD
BANKS AND WE AND WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE FOOD BANKS. IT
DOESN'T COVER SOME OF THE
REGULATORY COSTS. THAT HAVE
DRIVEN US INTO A VERY SPECIFIC
ON FLEXIBLE MARKET. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHOI HANSON
WILL MOVE NEXT TO SERRA FLOCKS
POLICY COORDINATOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
PLEASE BE MINDFUL. THAT WE'VE
OTHER PALACE ALSO WANT TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
I WILL GO VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THE QUESTION WITH
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC AND WE COVER
A LOT OF INDUSTRIES- BUT IN
TERMS OF. WHAT COULD BE DONE
DIFFERENTLY I MEAN I THINK ONE
THING WE NEED TO DO IS
DEFINITELY SHORE UP OUR OUR
SAFETY NET- OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM NEEDS. MASSIVE
REFORM TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN A
PROTECT PANDEMIC AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS LIKE THIS IN THE FUTURE
AND THEN I LOST SO AGREE WITH
MR NIGERIAN. OUR HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. WAS NOT PREPARED FOR
THAT SHOW ME THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A BIRDS EYE VIEW OF
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AND DIDN'T
KNOW HOW MANY HOSPITAL WHERE I
TO YOU THAT WE HAVE. IS ONE
PROBLEM THERE IS NO AGENCY
THAT. HAS OVERSIGHT OVER THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY WE HAVE. YOU
KNOW HEALTH PLAN REGULATORS
HOSPITAL REGULATORS. HOW TO
BAIL. YOU KNOW DATA COLLECTION
AND SO I DO THINK WE NEED TO DO
A BETTER JOB OF BEING ABLE TO.
TO UNDERSTAND OUR HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY AND DEPLOY RESOURCES
BOTH THE WORKFORCE AND AWFUL
SUPPLY. AND I'LL LEAVE IT THERE
FOR THE OTHER. FAMOUS FOR NEXT
WE WILL TO LAN HE'S PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. THE
I'M SORRY PHONE MODERATOR WE
WILL MOVE TO LANCE HE STANDS
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. AT A GLANCE
ACTUALLY DISCONNECTED. THANK
YOU PHONE MODERATOR WE WILL
MOVE NEXT TO RACHEL MICHELIN
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. LAP JUST RECONNECT
AND- WE'LL MOVE BACK TO LANCE
AFTER WE'RE FINISHED WITH WITH
MISS MICHELIN THANK YOU. OKAY
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WHY OUR SECTOR MIGHT LOOK
LIKE GOING FORWARD AND YOU KNOW
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE LIKE
THEM CHANGES AND WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN SOME CHANGES THERE'S BEEN
SOME MAJOR NATIONAL- RETAILERS
DATA DECLARED BANKRUPTCY- AND
WE ALSO HAVE THE NATIONAL
RETAILERS WHO ARE CLOSING. DOOR
NORDSTRAND AS AN EXAMPLE
ANNOUNCER COOKING SIXTEEN
STORES IN CALIFORNIA I AND MY
HEART A DATE WHY- SHRINKING OF
THE OF THE FOOTPRINT OF SOME OF
THE STORE WHICH I THINK WAS
XCELERATED BY THE PANDEMIC- I
THINK IT'S LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
WE HAD THAT ON MY MARKET PLACE
IS REALLY TAKING OFF I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING. THING TO LOOK AT
IS. ARE WE GOING TO SEE MORE
PEOPLE. SURE ON MY- AND NOT
GOING BACK INTO THE- WHICH THEY
WOULD MEAN BURKE AND MORE STORE
WOULD BE MORE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
MORE SO FORWARD. OR ARE WE
GOING TO SEE FOLKS WANTING TO
GO BACK INTO THE BROKEN WATER
STORAGE THIS IS THE
CONVERSATION THEY WERE HAVING
EVEN BEFORE THAT CAN'T GET A
CAT. AND AGAIN I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO DIVIDE IT
UP IN THE QUEUE KIND OF. I
THINK THE OTHER ISSUE AND I
WILL SAY THAT BACK. WHEN WE
SHUT DOWN AND WE WERE IN THE
SHELTER IN PLACE. IT DIDN'T
FEEL A LITTLE BIT AND IT FEELS
A LITTLE BIT MIKE BACK NOW THAT
WE TAKE. IN TERMS OF RETAIL
RETAILERS THAT CAN THAT ARE
WRITING IN THIS ECONOMY AND
WHAT BRAND AND RETAILERS THAT
ARE BEING PUT OUT OF BUSINESS
AND WE'RE PICKING KIND OF
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
BACKFIRED REALLY HOPE GOING
FORWARD WE KIND OF GET RID OF
THIS ESSENTIAL NONESSENTIAL I
THINK ALL BUSINESSES ARE
ESSENTIAL THE CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE SPECIAL TO THE ECONOMY
THERE ESSENTIAL TO OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY THIRD SPECIAL TO THAT.
THE FOLKS THAT WORK IN THE AND
ALL DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
BUSINESS. I SO I THINK FOR ME I
TALK REALLY WATCH THE IMPACT
SMALLER RETAIL. AND HOPING THAT
THEY CAN MAKE IT THROUGH YOU
MAY SEE THEM. VERY MAYBE A BIT
BETTER BECAUSE I THINK THERE
ARE FOLKS IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY WANT TO
GO WAITED OUTLOOK LOCAL
BOOKSTORE. LOCAL GET SHOT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THAT PERSONAL
CONNECTION AND THEY WANTED TO
BE THERE LOCAL START FEEDING.
AND BUT I THINK IT WILL BE
INTERESTING I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE WILL KNOW THE FULL IMPACT.
FOR ANOTHER. YOU KNOW A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AND TODAY AS A MATTER
OF FACT IN. CALCULATOR WEEKEND
ONE OF THE LARGEST SHOPPING
MALLS WITH OPENING. AND SO I'M
CURIOUS TO SEE HOW THAT WORK.
HE SAN DIEGO OPENING THE LAR
MARKET THEIR OPENING FOR. YOU
KNOW DO PEOPLE SHOW UP DO NINE
SO I THINK IT'S A LITTLE EARLY
TO BE- BUT THAT IMPACT IS BUT
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER. IF
THERE'S ONE THING THAT I
ENCOURAGE PARTICULARLY SMALLER
BUSINESSES IS THAT THEY DO HAVE
TO RETAKE GOING FORWARD THEIR
THEIR BUSINESS PLAN IN TERMS
THAT. ONLINE PRESENCE YOU KNOW
IF WE DO HAVE A SECOND WAVE
ENSURING THAT THEY CAN DO
CURBSIDE IF THEY CAN STILL NEW
AND GOODS TO THEIR STORES.
REALLY INCREASING YOUR ONLINE
PRESENCE AND HOPE THAT WE CAN.
IF WE DO GET IN ANOTHER
SITUATION LIKE THAT. RETAILERS
CAN STILL BE SOMEWHAT
COMPETITIVE AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE WOULD LOOK AT A BROADER.
YOU KNOW LOOK AT A BROADER
PERSPECTIVE AND REALLY NOT GET
INTO THIS ESSENTIAL
NONESSENTIAL I WOULD IN TURN
SAID THAT YOUR QUESTION ON THE
TRAINING AND THAT'S ACTUALLY AN
INTERESTING ONE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING A LOT OF INTERNAL
DISCUSSION. ARE NOT TRAINING
BECAUSE I THINK THAT- PART OF
OUR JOB AND IN THE ASSOCIATION
IS LOOKING AT THIS AND HOW CAN
WE TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO OUR
MEMBERS WHEN IT COMES TO
TRAINING AND YOU KNOW I LOOK AT
IT FROM A PERSPECTIVE THAT.
YEAH I CAN'T SERVICE IN A POINT
KIANA BORDER COMMISSION I TAKE
ONLINE TRAINING FOR MY ETHICS
TRAINING OR EXPECT A HARASSMENT
TO THE STATE IF WE DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. BUT WE CAL THEM FOR
YOU TO THAT THEY REALLY
UNDERSTAND ALL THE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS FROM THE GUIDELINES
THAT WERE PUT OUT BY THE STATE
IN IN DC. SO YOU KNOW WE'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH WITH THE
FAMILY MEMBER OTHER MEMBERS I'D
I THINK TRAIN. WORKERS I THINK.
INDUSTRY AND I'M TRYING TO TAKE
THAT ARE IT AS A LEADING
OFFENSE. FOR THE WEEK JUST CAL.
SHE PROVIDE THAT TYPE OF
TRAINING A THAT STATE HE NEEDS
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
A STATE SHOCKED CREDIT. SO THAT
CAN. AND LOCAL LACK THERE IS NO
THIS PARTICULAR RETAILER HAD
GONE FEEDBACK TRAINING. AND
THAT THEY ARE TRAINED IN ALL
THAT. THE GUY COMPRISES SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT AND-
WELCOME OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISS MICHELIN PHONE
MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE BACK TO
LANCE HASTINGS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHINA POLITICS UP
FOR DROPPING THE CALL I HAD. A
QUICK GENTLE AND THE TIME WAS
NOT DOES NOT IDEAL- REAL
BRIEFLY ON THE FIRST QUESTION.
MEANS TO BE SEEN WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT THE MANUFACTURING SECTOR
THEM THERE'S THREE SCHOOLS OF
THOUGHT. ONE IS THAT THERE'S
COULD BE TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC
SURGE- ONCE THINGS THAT NEED TO
RETURN TO SOME KIND OF NORMALCY
ANALOGY AS WE DID BEFORE THAT
THERE WILL NOT BE. A AN OLD
NORMAL THERE'S GOING TO BE A
NEW NORMAL- OF WAR AND CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR IS GOING TO RETRACT
AND REMAIN SELL FOR. AT LEAST
THE NEXT TWO QUARTERS MAYBE
INTO THAT MIDDLE PART OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAH THAT FOR US-
AGAIN YOU CAN'T CLICK ON THE
SWITCH TO THE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR THERE'S- A PLAN TO NEED
TO GO INTO PLACE. SUPPLY CHAIN
THE NEED TO BE SECURE IN
ANTICIPATION OF A CONSUMER
DEMAND. THAT IS WHAT IT IS AND-
SO WE ARE ALL STILL IN THE
LEARNING MODE. I'M HOPING OF
COURSE THAT THERE IS THAT- A
SURGE OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AS
THE SUMMER. BEGINS BUT. HELLO
BACK SEEING. HIS OWN. IT
APPEARS THAT FIRE BUT- BY. IN
ADDITION ALL THE OTHERS THAT'S-
AROUND THE WORLD THAT IS GOING
BE WITH US SOMETIME. IT IS THAT
CONSUMER. THAT'S REALLY GOING
TO BE- WATER TAKEN TO REWRITING
THE PUBLIC BEHAVIOR. THAT IS
GOING TO BE AROUND THE TERM- ON
HOW MUCH AND HOW FAR WE CAN.
REOPEN ECONOMY AND- RICHARD
THIS ELECTRONIC ACTIVITY- ON
THE SECOND QUESTION A REAL
CURIOUS WHEN THE DEADLINE CAME
OUT FOR THE MAN BACK. SECTOR WE
REVIEW THEM. WE JUST. WHAT WE
KNEW ALREADY IS THAT THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. AND
SAFETY IT'S SUCH A CRITICAL
COMPONENT FACTORING. THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY ADAPTED THE NEW
CRACK. INTO A- MANUFACTURING
PROCESSES BUT WE HAVE IN THE
STORAGE- YOU SHOULD PHD THAT
OUR EMPLOYEES IN OUR OPERATIONS
ARE USED TO IT EXPECTED. THE
MANY. ANYBODY PUT ON I
PROTECTION. LIKELY YOUR
PROTECTION AND I'M KIND PUT
PROTECTION IN ORDER JUST TO
VISIT THE FACILITY. SO THEY'RE
ABLE TO DOUBT THAT- AS WAS.
POINTED OUT IN THE- BEFORE I IF
YOU HAVE ONE CRITIC POINT OF WE
CAN REALLY GO CHALLENGES LIKE
AND MINORITY. MAN INTO THE
COMMUTER SO I THINK THAT THE
MANY. SIDE THE IF YOU ENTER A-
MANY BACK TO SELL YOU PROBABLY
ALREADY GO THROUGH. SOME OF THE
AT PVO YOU CAN AS THE TRACES
PROVIDED AN INFORMATIONAL
POSTER TO NOT JUST OUR MEMBERS
BUT TO THE ENTIRE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR. THAT LINKS- A GREAT
DEAL OF INFORMATION IT PROVIDES
GUIDELINES ON AND TO BE PUT ON
THE VERY FRONT DOOR THAT EVERY
FACILITIES AS YOU WALK INTO OUR
APPROACH A CUSTODIAL NOW THAT
AND THEY ARE TAKING THE
INCREASED PROTOCOL APARTMENT
THAT QUITE SERIOUSLY. YEAH BABY
JUST A QUICK MOMENT AS I CLOSE
TO SAY THAT YES IT'S A PANDEMIC
YESTER SOME HEALTH-
REQUIREMENTS YOU NEED TO BE-
CIRCULATED AROUND BUT IT'S THE
COMMUNICATIONS EFFORTS FROM ALL
OF OUR INDUSTRY GROUPS
INCLUDING OUR OWN THAT REALLY
PROVIDE THE GLUE. ATTACK GET
THE INFORMATION OUT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO GATHER IN A
TRULY IS A COMMUNICATIONS
ORIENTED RECOVERY THAT WERE
ABOUT TO ENTER INTO BECAUSE
WITH WITHOUT COMMUNICATION NOT
REALLY KNOW HOW TO PROCEED. AND
THE CHALLENGE OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS PROFESSIONALS
WORK IN ALL OF OUR INDUSTRY
TRADE GROUPS AND MEDIA FOR
COULD YOU KNOW TO CARL AND AT
THE T. A BUT IN TERMS OF
KEEPING MANUFACTURES AND FOR.
AN ENGAGED- THAT BECOMES
FUNCTIONS CRITICAL HOLE IN
THAT'LL. ARENA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER HASTIE. PHONE
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO MATT
SUDDEN AND I WASN'T ADMONISH
ANYONE PARTICULAR I SAID PLEASE
KEEP. QUESTION YOUR AND TO
REGIONAL AMOUNT OF TIME. YOUR
ANSWER IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AND
WE WANT TO GET IMPORTANT
INFORMATION OUT OF THOSE
ANSWERS- BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THAT TIME- THAT WE
HAVE AS WELL SO MR SEND PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR MODERATE.
CERTAINLY MISTER CHAIR I'LL
KEEP THAT IN MIND APPRECIATE
IT- YEAH BUILDING ON THAT
WITNESS MICHELIN SAID- SAID
THAT HE AND THE TO YOUR
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY AND- YOU KNOW THERE'S
TWO TWO THINGS SAID TO STYLUS
REALLY WHAT WE KNOW AND WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN THE RESTAURANT
SPACE AND- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
KNOW. AND LEARN THE TRACE JUST
A WEEK OR TWO AGO FROM
ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BOERNER HORVATH WHICH IS RE
IMAGINING RESTAURANT AND YOU
KNOW I KNEW THE CONCEPT BUT SHE
GOING TO TURN AND IT IS EXACTLY
TRUE BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE
KNOW THAT RESTAURANTS ARE NOT.
FEEL A BIT DIFFERENTLY GO FOR.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT CONSUMER DEMAND IT'S GOING
TO BE- THERE'S A LOT OF
INDICATORS THAT CONSUMERS ARE
READY TO GET SOME SEMBLANCE OF
NORMALCY BACK. IN YOU KNOW A
MONTH AGO IT WOULD HAVE SAID.
PHYSICAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERINGS. CONTACTLESS PAYMENTS
TO HAND SANITIZER THROUGHOUT
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT WOULD
HAVE SAID BOY. THOSE ARE GOING
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE IN THE
RESTAURANT SETTING BUT YOU KNOW
NO WHAT WE KNOW NOW. AND HAVING
LIMITED OPERATIONS FOR THE LAST
MONTH OR TWO I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THESE THINGS AND
ESPECIALLY AS COUNTIES ARE RE
OPENING NOW. THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT CONSUMERS WANT TO.
AND WHEN THEY WALK INTO A
RESTAURANT THESE THINGS HAVE
BEEN SOMEONE NORMALIZED NOW.
AND SO THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
WILL MAKE THEM COMFORTABLE
WHICH IS AN IRONY COMPARED TO
WHERE WE WERE WEEKS AGO. SO THE
POINT IS THAT GOING TO THE
NORTH FOR THE FIRST. FUTURE
SEEING THINGS THAT HAVING THESE
PROTOCOLS. TEACHERS KLAY BUT
NOT JUST THE STATE OF THAT FIND.
A DATE COMMITTEE. BUT THE FIFTY
EIGHT CAN SUPPORT CITIES THAT
HAVE THEIR OWN HEALTH THE- ARE
IN GUIDELINE PROTOCOLS OF A
LOCAL NATURE. SO IT NOT THREE.
THROUGHOUT STATE YOU COULD
ARGUE IT PART A LITTLE CLUNKY
BUT FOR THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY. THAT IS THE SYSTEM
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT- HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS RISK ASSESSMENT ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO OPEN UP AT
DIFFERENT PACES WHICH- FOR US.
GETTING ANY OF THESE OPENINGS
BACK IN A SAFE MANNER IT'S
HELPFUL. SO THE FUTURE WE'RE
NOT EALLY SURE THE CONSUMER
DEMANDS MISTER HASTINGS IN THIS
MICHELIN STATED- THAT THE
QUESTION- BUT WE DO THINK THE
MORE OF THESE PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES- THAT ARE IN PLACE.
THE MORE CUSTOMERS WILL COME
BACK AND OUR GUESTS ARE ALSO
VERY INTERESTED IN NEW AND
DIFFERENT DINING EXPERIENCES
AND SO WE'RE WORKING WITH LOCAL
CITY GOVERNMENTS. TO CHANGE
ORDINANCES TO ALLOW GREATER USE
ABOUT DOOR AREAS FOR DINING ABC
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL IT'S
ALSO BEEN. VERY HELPFUL IN
THE PROCESS THAT PEOPLE CAN GO
THROUGH- TO HAVE OUTDOOR DINING
WITH ALCOHOL SERVICE TO SOME
DEGREE IF APPROVED. SO YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE CITY STREET SHUT
DOWN SIDEWALKS USED TO A
GREATER EXTENT PUBLIC THOROUGH
WAYS ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS TO HELP ACCOMMODATE. THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING AND I
THINK ALL OF THOSE MEASURES
TOGETHER ARE GONNA HELP
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AND WE WILL
SEE PEOPLE COME BACK TO
RESTAURANT. ON A DIM NOT THE
SWITCH BUT I DO THINK THAT'S
WHAT. THE AS FOR THE SPECIFIC.
AT THERE BRING. YEAH I WOULD
SAY THIS IN THERE ARE NEWMAN
PRE ALREADY IN PLACE PRIOR TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN NOBODY DOES
FOOD SAFETY BETTER THAN THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY IT'S ONE
OF THE SAFEST PLACES TO EAT
MORE THAN MOST PEOPLE HOME
KITCHENS AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF
ALL THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
MANDATE TO PROGRAMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PUT FORTH IN
THAT COME WITH IT REPORTED-
THAT OUR IN PLACE. AND SO HE TO
YOU TOO IN THE MANSION YES
GOING FORWARD THERE ARE ALSO A
LOT OF NEW- SUGGESTIONS
PROTOCOL THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND OUR BIGGEST
THING TO OUR MEMBERS HAS BEEN
HEY YOUR IN A GATE RIGHT NOW I
KNOW YOU'RE UPSET BECAUSE OF
THAT GATE BUT DO NOT GET OUT OF
THE GATE DOOR OPENS SELECT FEW
SPENCER DAYS PUTTING THE NEW
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE AND THE NEW
PROTOCOL SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
EXAMPLE HAVE MANDATORY HAND
WASHING INTERVALS THROUGHOUT
THE DAY THAT'S KIND OF NORMAL
THE- FOOD SAFETY IS WHAT WE DO
SO THIS IS WHAT WORK THAT AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THE- YOU KNOW
THERE'S GOING TO SNACKS WITH
NEW TRAINING AND- LOCAL HEALTH.
IT BILLION ONE FORCE THAT AND
IT THEATER THE H. OF THE RIGHT.
HIS WRIST. TO CAN. TO OUR-
ABOUT THE NEW BEST PRACTICES
PROCEDURES PROTOCOLS THINGS
THAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING AND
AGAIN DO THEM BEFORE YOU OPEN
YOUR DOORS. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
QUESTION TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. OF MANY OF THESE
PROCEDURES AND REQUIREMENTS ARE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL BUT
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE ADDITIONAL
STAFF TRAINING. AND THAT IS
WHAT WE DO BEST AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO RISING TO THE
OCCASION. AND DOING JUST THAT
BUT- YOU KNOW I HEAR YOU- I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SO AND I
THINK THAT MISTER NAZARIAN HAS
SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. WELL
IT'S MORE OF A COMMENT MATT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WANTING
TO. GET INTO THE DETAILS OF
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT BUT JUST
SO I REITERATE THE POINT THIS
IS THIS WAS NOT AT ALL TO. PICK
ON ON THE TO MAKE A CRITIC
CRITICISM OF THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY OR SECTOR I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE'S BEEN ON HEIGHTENED
ALERT AND WORKING VERY
CAREFULLY. AT MY POINT ABOUT
THAT WAS JUST THAT IN ANY
SYSTEM YOU CAN TAKE. VERY
PAINSTAKING. STEPS AND
IMPLEMENT PROCESSES THAT
OVERHAULS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
BUT THEN ALL IT TAKES IS. IN A
AT ONE SMALL STEP A SIMPLE
THING DOESN'T HAPPEN AND SO IT
COMPROMISES THE INTEGRITY OF
THAT ENTIRE OVERHAULIN CHANGER
THAT SYSTEM THAT YOU HAD NEWLY
SET UP AND SO THAT WAS THE
POINT IN AND THE POINT WAS THAT
THIS CAN HAPPEN IN ANY INDUSTRY
ALSO- SO THAT'S WHY IT WASN'T
AT ALL. TO PINPOINT IT WAS JUST
THE BEST EXAMPLE GIVEN MY
EXPERIENCE AT A LOCAL
RESTAURANT OTHERWISE IT'S VERY
MUCH APPLICABLE TO EVERYTHING
ELSE SO THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MATT. I THANK YOU MISTER YEAH
AND I YEAH I THINK. WE'VE GOT
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION HE
WASN'T SPECIFICALLY CALLING OUT
RESTAURANTS IT WAS AN
ILLUSTRATION OF WHERE AND THE
STATE CAN BE MADE AND THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN ANY INDUSTRY SO THAT.
IT WAS WHAT THE POINT WAS MADE
AND IT WAS NOT AT. AT ALL.
SELECT YOUR INDUSTRY SO THANK
YOU. SO PHONE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE. PUT LANCE
HASTINGS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU HERE YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO WE HEARD A LOT
EARLY ON ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
LACK OF USE OF THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT AND- AND WHETHER
OR NOT THAT WAS GOOD WEATHER
WAS BAD WEATHER WAS EVEN
POSSIBLE. TO RETOOL MACHINES TO
DO SOME OF THE WORK THAT-
PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE DONE WE
TALK ABOUT TOO MANY FACTORS OF
PP SPECIFICALLY HERE IN- IN
CALIFORNIA BUT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT WHAT WHAT THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIKE OR HOW HOW SLOW- OR
QUICKLY SOMETHING LIKE THAT
COULD HAVE WORKED IF. THE
PRESIDENT DID IN FACT USE IT IF
IT WAS EVEN POSSIBLE AND YOU
KNOW CONVERSATIONS WITH
INDUSTRY ABOUT THAT. YEAH I
MEAN IT'S ALL ACCIONES WE'VE
LEARNED SOMETHING EVERY NEW DAY
AT THIS. CRISIS AND WE BAD DID
BUT I AND I HOPE THAT THAT
POLICY MAKERS LOOK BACK. ONCE
WE DO GET YOU THROUGH THIS
INITIAL. RUN WITH COCA
NINETEEN. FIFTY WILL WORK AND
WHAT NEEDED TO BE ADAPTED. TO
THE DEPEND PROTECTION ACT I'M
SEASON PRODUCTION ACT OF
COURSE. IS A DRASTIC STEP. IT
COMMANDEERS A FACILITY AND
REQUIRES PRODUCTION OF CERTAIN
MATERIALS. ON THE CHALLENGE
WITH THAT IS MAKING SURE THAT
THERE S A SUPPLY CHAIN THAT
CAN BACK THAT UP. AND THAT IS
NOT ALWAYS THE CASE IN SOME
TIMES AS WE TALKED BEFORE THAT
GLOBAL- THAT SUPPLY CHAIN IS
AVAILABLE ONLY GLOBAL. IN
GETTING THAT MATERIAL TO THE
UNITED STATES FOR PRODUCTION I
BECAME JOB ONE WHICH IS WHY I
MENTION THE PORT ACTIVITY. ON
THE WEST COAST TO THE AND THE
CRITICALLY A VITALLY IMPORTANT-
I THINK WHAT COULD DO THAT WE
COULD HAVE BEEN DONE. BUT THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT CLEAR
KNOWLEDGE MINT. WE NEEDED ACT.
WHETHER THAT WAS A FACEMASK OR
HIS DATA TIZER. AND THEN- URGE
THE INDUSTRY SECTOR THAT-
PRODUCES THOSE TEMP TO MAKE
BECAUSE I. AM A NINETY FIVE
MAPS ARE IN VERY SHORT SUPPLY
AS WE ALL KNOW BUT THERE IS A
MEDICAL APPLICATION. AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT. AT
PRODUCT IT'S NOT THAT THE YOU
CAN JUST HIT THE- YOU'RE
OPERATIONS AND IF I AM. HERE
HASTY TEXTILE. MADE THAT COULD
SERVICE MAKING A NINETY FIVE.
WITH IN MAYBE. THAT IF NOTHING
ELSE FROM WAY UP WE CAN THE
KIND OF THE SPELL THE NOTION
THAT. DEMAND CAN MAKING. IN A
UNIT IN ME PIVOT. WE CAN
ADAPTER UPPER OVER TO WHICH IS
A WE'RE DOING UP FOR THE NON
MEDICAL. PP BUT IT IS.
CONTINGENT SUPPLY CHAIN. YEAH I
THINK I DON'T SPEAK FOR MY- CAR
PARTS- IN THE AGAN- GOOD
ACTORS. THAT LEADS TO THE GIRL
IN THE BACK ROOM AT THE GROCERY
STORE. I MEAN IT COMES FROM
SOMEWHERE. AND WE ALL NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN IS. VERY INTERTWINED WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND GETTING- ITEMS
AND THEN PRODUCTS TO THE
CONSUMER. THAT IS NOT EASY THAT
MAY APPEAR MONEY THEIR TV ARE
ARE KIND OF HOUSE PRESENTED
SOMETIMES. SO THAT THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION IF THE DRAFTING STEP.
ONE WE SEEN NOT TO BE. MATHIS
BUT EVERY SINGLE DAY. THIS
CRISIS HAS EVOLVED. WITH
DIFFERENT NEEDS IN DIFFERENT
PROPERTY ON ANY GIVEN DAY OR
WEEK. AND ARE YOU TO ADAPT TO
THAT. I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY
PROVEN. INEFFECTIVE AGAIN YOU
CAN START TO SEE. THAT HE IN
PLACE ON OUR STREETS AND NEVER
SEEN IT BEFORE. PRIMARILY
BECAUSE THAT MANY TAX SECTORS
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE ITEMS. DO
YOU YOUR INTEREST FOR. ONLY NOW
TO MISS JOE HAS. WHO IS HERE
THE ROOM FROM THE CAL FARM
BUREAU WANTED FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU A- YOU KNOW THERE'S TALK
ABOUT. TO IN SOME AIR. OR OR A-
SCARCITY IN IN OTHERS AND THE-
THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD WITH FOOD
BANKS FOR EXAMPLE AND- YOU KNOW
THE THAT THAT WAS SO HELPFUL.
TO SO MANY SO QUICKLY- ACROSS
THE STATE CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT. YEAH AND- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
SACRAMENTO- YOU KNOW WORKING ON
THOSE INCENTIVES FOR FARMERS TO
HELP COVER COSTS OF HARVESTING
ONE OF THE- TOUGHEST QUESTIONS
WE GOT NEWS THAT ARTICLE I'D
READ IN A- VALLEY NEWSPAPER- IN
ONE PART OF THE CITY OF FARMER
DISKIN UNDER. YOU KNOW LETTUCE
HER OR HIS CROP AND THEN OF
COURSE. A FOOD BANK THAT WILL
SHORTEN HOW DO WE GET THERE AND
WHY THE DISKETTE UP BECAUSE YOU
KNOW BUT THE ULTIMATE THING IS
YOU HAVE A FARMER WHO IS YOU
KNOW. PROBABLY GOING TO
STRUGGLE FOR THE REST YEAR TO
HANG ON AND SURVIVE. IT STILL
COSTS MONEY TO HARVEST IT STILL
COSTS MONEY FOR THE MANPOWER-
IN A TO HARVEST AND THEN TO GET
IT TO- TO A FOOD BANK AND
TRUCKING COSTS AND EVERYTHING
THEN WE ALSO HAD KIND OF SORT
OF A LABOR SHORTAGE. BECAUSE
SEVERAL SHELTER IN PLACE SO TO
THE GOVERNOR CREDIT- CALLING
OUT THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
ASSIST IN TERMS OF MANPOWER.
ONE OF MY LOOK GOING TO NEED
DISCUSS AS WELL AS A STORAGE
CAPACITY OF THOSE FOOD BANKS-
WE CAN THE PRODUCT TO THEM BUT-
A LOT OF IT IS PERISHABLE- IF
NOT REFRIGERATED SO AND WE CAN
THAT'S- IN WITH. ON WORK. A
FULL BANKS GETTING HERE THAT
WELL BUT ALSO TO HOW DO WE-
THIS IS MORE ON JUST FEW
DISTURBING CAN. WORKING WITH
THE USDA YOU'RE SEEING NOW FOOD
BOX PROGRAM COME ONLINE- BUT
YOU'LL ALSO SEE IN JULY NOW-
FARMERS TO FAMILY- PROGRAM TO
USD AND WORKING WITH THE FOOD
BANKS. BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
IN TERMS OF THE REGULATION
STAYING AWAY BEING APPROVED
VENDOR THROUGH THE USDA TO
DISTRIBUTE ACCESS COMMODITIES
BECAUSE SECTION THIRTY TO. A
DISTRIBUTION A PROGRAMMER THE
FUNDS COME FROM BUT HOW DO WE
STREAMLINED WHO IS QUALIFIED TO
ACCESS FUNDING THROUGH THE U.
S. T. IN SOME OF THEIR PROGRAMS
TO DISTRIBUTE. TO THOSE IN NEED
WELL SO THERE'S A LOT. IS IN A
BOOK FOCUS ON STEP WE'VE BEEN
THE ASKING FOR A WHILE NOW THE
URGENCY. IS A. A GREAT GIFT.
THANK YOU MISS MICHELIN'S WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
TRENDS AND HOW- IT WAS UNCLEAR
WHAT THE TRENDS ARE GOING TO
BE. PRE PANDEMIC ABOUT. WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK TO BRICK
AND MORTAR AS A SHOPPING
EXPERIENCE AND CERTAINLY. A
NEED OR DESIRE FOR PEOPLE TO
GET OUT OF THEIR HOME- AT POST
PANDEMIC IF THAT'S GOING TO
SHIFT OR CONTINUE TO MOVE. INTO
A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE WANT TO
HAVE THAT IN PERSON EXPERIENCE.
YOU'RE ALSO SEEN. WHAT WHAT
RESTAURANTS FOR CHALLENGED BY
WHICH WAS A CURBSIDE PICK UP.
AND WHETHER THAT SOME A RETAIL
EXPERIENCE THAT THAT CONSUMERS
ARE GOING TO BE. SEEKING AS
WELL. ONE ONE THING THAT WE'VE
HEARD THROUGH THE PANDEMIC IS.
THAT SOME NATIONAL RETAILERS.
HAVE NOT PAID RENT. AND THAT'S
PROBABLY MOM AND POP STORES HER
**** DOING THAT AS WELL- THAT I
KNOW OF- HOW IS THAT LONG TERM.
GOING TO CHANGE ANY OF THE
TRENDS AND WILL THERE BE AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR MOVEMENT THAT
MAKES THE YOU KNOW CURSE PER
SQUARE FOOTAGE SALES- FORMULA
DIFFERENT. BASED ON. ANY
MOVEMENT ON BECAUSE- OVER. A
REALIST. FOR RETAILERS. THE
GREAT QUESTION I THINK THAT.
THAT'S DEFINITELY I TRY WHERE
LOW OUT BUT MINUTE HOW BECAUSE
WE SAT A IF YOU KNOW ONE
EXPECTING AT. A LOT OF THE
BUSINESS PROPER WERE WORKING
WITH SOME OF THEIR CAñADA CAN
TURN OF MAYBE CAPTAIN ON THEIR-
TO THE AND THAT AT LEAST.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
HOW. I HAD TRYING TO KEEP THEM
IN IN THAT SHOPPING CHEN
BECAUSE THEY WANTED AND THAT
THEY HAVE TENANTS WHAT THE
PRODUCT PASS NO ONE REALLY KNEW
HOW LONG WITH ACT LOOK AT THE
LAST. I'M I DO THINK THAT BACK
GOING TO BE A GREATER. MARK TO
HAVE TO HAVE. I THINK YOU MIGHT
SEE SOME SHRINK AT WORK IT YEAH
CAL WORK YOU COULD NOT A LARGE.
AND YOU KNOW NASH BRANDS ACRES
WITH THEM OF THEM ALL DEPEND ON
HOW THE RECOVERY DOES DEPENDING
ON HOW THE GO YOU KNOW ON WHO
YOU TALK TO. THEM BOTH THANK
YOU MIGHT YEAH AT A GREAT
LICCARDO QUICKER THAN PEOPLE
ARE IN MY BE A SLOW RECOVERY
THERE'S FACT. BUT I THINK THAT
GONNA BE A AT A REALLY BIG
ISSUE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
SOME OF THE LARGER ONLINE.
STORES THAT ARE OFTEN NOW
LOOKING AT POSSIBLY BY SOME OF
WE CAN THE NATIONAL WE THAT ARE
FILED. SO I THINK YOU'RE TO BE
NEXT YOU MIGHT THINK CHAU. AND
WE THAT WILL AT THAT FOR THAN
WHAT SEEN IN THE PAST. I BUT I
DO THINK IT IS OF THE RIGHT THE
WORK FOR. EIGHTY FOUR WEEKS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PROBABLY
LIKE FAN COUNTY TO WORK WITH.
HEARING ON HAND I LOOKING AT A
JULY OPEN. AND OF PEOPLE BY
THIRTY SENT A LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR I THINK. AFTER FOR
MORE VERY IT'S BUT THE COUNTY
TO OPEN. AND BUT ONE THREE SEE
THE MORE OPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
REALLY SEE WHAT BECAUSE WHO IS
GOING TO BE I BACK FROM WILL BE
ABLE ANSWER THAT BACK. AND MARK
AND I'D TO BACK IN OR HAVE.
THERE I THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US ON A KIND AND THEY'RE
REGIONALLY YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S WITH OTHER STATES IN AND
YOU SEE THE TRENDS NATIONALLY
WITH LABOR LAWS AND PROTECTIONS
DO YOU THINK THAT WE WILL NEED
MORE LEGISLATION DUE TO THAT
THE PANDEMIC AND HOW TO PROTECT
WORKERS OR DO YOU THINK THAT
FROM A REGULATORY STANDPOINT
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR LET'S
JUST BE SPECIFIC ABOUT
CALIFORNIA IS IN A PLACE TO
PROMULGATE- CODES AND
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT PEOPLE-
NECESSARY- GIVEN THE RISKS
THAT. THAT WE'RE FACING. I'M I
THINK CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY
VERY GOOD LABOR LAW. I THINK WE
MAY HAVE LOST MISS FLOCKS.
THERE ARE MINOR YES SHE
DISCONNECTED OKAY WILL WILL
COME BACK TO HER- PHONE
MODERATOR CAN WE PLEASE HAVE
MATTHEW SUTTON SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AT THE HEAD MATH.
THANK YOU O MISTER SUTTON THE
BIG QUESTION I HAVE AND I THINK
A LOT OF US- WHO ARE STRUGGLING
SUPPORTER LOCAL RESTAURANTS SIR
OR DEALING WITH IT IS- THAT- WE
HAVE HEARD THAT THE FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICES THAT UBER
EATS THE DOOR DASHES ARE TAKING
AN ENORMOUS CUT. OUT OF THE
FOOD- THAT THE COST OF THE
FOOD- WHEN YOU'RE BUYING FROM A
RESTAURANT IN THE RESTAURANTS
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MORE
OF AN IN PERSON OR AT LEAST-
YOU KNOW AWAITED DIRECTLY HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PERSON
BUYING THE FOOD. HOW HOW REAL
IS THAT RISK OR ARE THOSE
SERVICES ACTUALLY HELPING
PEOPLE GET THROUGH- THAT THE
STATE HOME ORDER- OR WAS IT
JUST MERELY A BANDAID THAT TIED
WASN'T SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- WE'RE
WE'RE CERTAINLY GLAD TO BE AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE IN THE EARLY
PHASES OF RE OPENING AND TO
HELP IMPLEMENT TAKEOUT ORDERING
AND DELIVERY. THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES HAVE HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN HELPFUL AND
CRUCIAL TO THAT WE CAN'T
SURVIVE ON TAKEOUT AND DELIVERY
ALONE- SO THAT IS THAT IS
CERTAINLY A BANDAID BUT GOING
FORWARD- YOU KNOW THERE'S AN
EMPHASIS ON CONTINUING.
DELIVERY AND TAKEOUT BUT DINING
ROOMS ARE SLOWLY REOPENING AS
AS WE KNOW SO- THEY'LL BE A
COMBINATION OF BOTH I DO THINK
THAT TAKE OUT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A LARGE. LARGE PORTION OF
THE BUSINESS WE DO- INTO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT SOME OF THOSE-
IRRITANTS THAT RESTAURANTS HAVE
WITH REGARD TO UPWARDS OF 30%
TAKES ON EACH ORDER- THAT A
CUSTOMER MAKES WHEN THEY DO THE
DELIVERY. THAT YEAH THAT'S IT
THAT'S AN IRRITANT IT'S AN
ISSUE OF CONTINUE DISCUSSION
AND- SOME OF THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY GRANT TO SUSPEND IT
DOES IN THE- IN THE MIDST OF
THE CRISIS- AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT- AND THAT IT
THAT THAT THE- BIG COMPLICATED
ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW AT THIS
POINT WHERE WE'RE- GRATEFUL
THAT SOME OF THE BRANDS HAVE.
OF SUSPENDED SOME OF THEIR
COMMISSIONS ARE LIMITED THEM IT
IS A SENATE'S HOPPING FROM A
RESTAURANT TO DELIVERY SERVICE
COMPANY. RELATIONSHIP OR IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
RETAILER EVER PARTY THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION- OTHERS
ARE HAVING. MORE GLOBAL
CONVERSATION WITH THEM ABOUT
HOW TO GET THROUGH THIS WITHOUT
ONEROUS FEES. THANK YOU WERE
SIR HAVE A AND HAVE FOR QUITE A
LONG TIME HAVING DISCUSSIONS
WITH SOME OF THE INDIVIDUAL
THIRD PARTY DELIVERY COMPANIES-
BUT- YEAH GENERALLY THESE ARE
WORKED OUT BETWEEN THE
RESTAURANT AND THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANY- AND THEN YOU
KNOW LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO- HAVE GONE FORWARD
WITH THEIR OWN LOCAL ORDINANCES
AND- MANY MANY OTHER LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE LOOKING AT
DOING THEIR LOW. ON LOCAL
ORDINANCES ON THIS TOPIC IN AND
OTHERS AS IT RELATES TO THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY. I THANK YOU
MISTER SUTTON FUN MODERATORS
MISS FOX BACK ON THE LINE. HI
MISTER STANLEY MEMBER YES I'M
ON THE LINE THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE. I APOLOGIZE MY
HUSBAND AND I ARE WORKING AT
HOME AND WE DON'T HAVE FULL
BAND WITH- YES I THINK
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAWS ARE VERY
STRONG AND GOOD ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY RIGHT NOW LIKE I
MENTIONED CAL OSHA IN TERMS OF
ENFORCING THAT- WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY RE OPENING
GUIDELINES IT'S GONNA BE KEY.
THAT THEY HAVE A FULL FINDING
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO HIRE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND ALSO
HAVE APPROPRIATE PP-
ENFORCEMENT OF EIGHTY FIVE IT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL- THE AG
HAVE A LAWSUIT BUT- AT T. ALSO
NEEDS TO START COLLECTING BACK
TAXES FROM COMPANIES THAT MS
CLASSIFY- UBER AND LET ALONE-
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- TO THAT YOU Y.
FUND WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL IN
IN PROPPING UP THAT BUNCH. AND
I DO THINK SOME OF THAT-
EMERGENCY ORDERS THE GOVERNOR
HAS ORDERED EACH AND SOME OF
EVEN THE FEDERAL LAWS THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE IN TERMS SAYS
QUOTE UNQUOTE EMERGENCY. JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE AND PAID LEAVE
ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND NOT JUST
IMPORTANT DURING EMERGENCIES
STATE WE SHOULD CONSIDER
EXTENDING THAT AND JUST LIKE I
HAD MENTIONED SOME OF THESE
ESSENTIAL WERE REALLY
SACRIFICIAL WORKERS. I THINK WE
NEED TO LOOK AT. WORKERS THAT
DURING A PANDEMIC WE DEEM
ESSENTIAL. THAT NOT INTENDED
AMERICORPS CONSIDERED MINIMUM
WAGE ALMOST DISPOSABLE WORKERS
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW.
AT INCREASING THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND MAKING SURE THAT WORKERS
HAVE THE BENEFITS PROTECTION
THE DIGNITY THAT THEY DESERVE
FOR THE WORK THAT I THINK
FRANKLY BE UNDERVALUED-
ESPECIALLY IN CARE INDUSTRIES
THE ONES WERE TAKING CARE OF
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR ELDERLY
WORKING IN NURSING HOMES AND
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU MISS
FLOCKS AND WILL PUT ABOUT THE
DIGNITY OF EVERY JOB THAT
EVERYONE HAS AND I FEEL YOUR
PAIN ON THE BAND WITH ISSUE AT
HOME AS SOME WITH TWO CHILDREN-
LEARNING BY ZOOM AND A WIFE WHO
ALSO WORKS- IT. WE'RE ALL
WORKING FROM HOME EXCEPT FOR A
DAY LIKE TODAY WERE IN HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. I THINK A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS CAN IDENTIFY WITH
WITH THAT CHALLENGE. SO I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
PANELISTS THIS SERVICE IS BEEN
A VERY INFORMATIVE HEARING I AM
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
I'M GRATEFUL FOR- THE
LEADERSHIP IN AND WORK THAT TO
YOUR DOING TO HELP. I GET SO
MANY- IN YOUR INDUSTRIES
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC. AND SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR JUST THIS
GREAT- INFORMATIVE BRIEFING
HERE FOR THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I THINK ALSO FOR
THE PUBLIC- WHO- WANT TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THAT. I'D
ALL AT THIS POINT LIKE TO
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT SO THE
PUBLIC IS WELCOME TO PROVIDE
COMMENT USING THE FOLLOWING
TOLL FREE PHONE NUMBER. THAT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS
SEVEN THREE FOUR. FIVE ONE
THREE ONE. FOR MODERATORS OR
ANYONE THAT IS HERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE. BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT THERE
IS NO ONE. OKAY LESS BECAUSE I
GIVE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES
PHONE NUMBER. I THAT'S JUST A
CHOKE. SEC HEY THANK YOU AGAIN-
PHONE MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP TODAY
YOU DD A FANTASTIC JOB THANK
YOU TO THE PANELISTS THANK YOU
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF-
MACHINES HAVE TERRY SHINES MY
LEGISLATIVE A DIEGO LOPEZ WHO
WORKED VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WENT SMOOTHLY THINK
YOU GUYS ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE HARD WORK I KNOW IT'S A
REAL STRUGGLE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO MAKE SURE THESE
THINGS GO OFF WITHOUT A HITCH.
WE'VE GOT SOME AMAZING STAFF.
IN THE ROOM SERGEANTS AND
SERVICES- OF THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU GUYS FOR KEEPING US SAFE
AND MAKING AN ORDERLY. MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
APPROPRIATELY DISTANCED- AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE WHO
TUNED IN. HAVE A GREAT DAY
THIS. COMMITTEE HEARING IS
CLOSED.